like we're going
live as [ __ ]
why don't we put them we live in the
darkest i don't know that's what i was
wearing i can't see eddie barely
why did he also work are you live just
like in the metaphor brothers you can't
talk when someone else is talking
what there's like five people here
we'll have a talking stick also i didn't
hear anyone talking
phillip was talking
what were you saying that's
important don't know we can't hear you
that's part of the problem you're not on
our channel
i'm on the people's channel
i'm on b-e-t get on our wavelength dude
maybe we should take our headphones off
in solidarity for riley
it's fine bro i kind of like how i sound
in the headphones though the cans do
sound nice it's good i'll go rogue i
don't care solidarity
let us know if you're also keeping my
ears warm
um maybe we should turn can you guys
hear me i'm on my own channel
the yellow one was the justin's that
just maxed out
just x out can you is there a way to
make me less white
how did it max out they maxed out the
input let us know if this is it all
sounds like there's a way to turn down
my saturation
[Laughter]
can riley and eddie switch
yeah
yeah
no we're gonna get the pantones right
so kyle rittenhouse was found in a set
riley you can read the chats for us
he said what the hell it looks like
gypsy heaven
thanks that's racist
what is it this giant brown tarp in the
back it's uh we're actually in uh the
isis warehouse yeah uh dallas
dallas isis warehouse the next
weeds
sash i mean tobacco so uh as you can see
our careers are working out pretty well
yeah we all moved into this garage
can we get more tarps
the tarps cover up more [ __ ] there's
like just boxes and shits we should get
that sex on the city poster in frame
that'll add some color
nice pointing up things that aren't on
camera i'm just gonna say we have eddie
take one ear off so that we can all
listen to riley
hey it's fine you guys can't hear me
it's coffee any good yeah it's good i
don't need you guys to hear me
yeah you just talk to yourself i'll talk
to myself i'll have like my own separate
podcast
this is two podcasts in one
riley's solo podcast and us for so this
is eddie trevino
uh when what are you gonna say about
dallas
uh dallas is um
is a sacred place uh
i um compared to austin uh it is um
nice it's uh it's it's uh it's new york
no i'm just kidding uh
austin is austin is pretty dope um
dallas dallas has been my home but would
you say austin is the dallas of texas
no
no there's no i don't know man austin is
it's uh there was there was a thing i
used to do when i go to austin and and i
would say like uh
we would uh give a over under how many
times we say weird
but like it has to be like natural it
couldn't just be made uh like keep
awesome weird yeah so we will see some
weird [ __ ] like we'll just say weird oh
that's weird yeah let's keep that's
weird yeah
the over under like 18 19. we'll always
go over there's a lot of weird it
depends what's considered weird
i mean
you know you knew austin before we got
there violent people living
and there's a whole history
that we don't even know about of austin
there's like famous weird people in
austin like there's the rooster guy have
you met him yes
like he was i was like nice [ __ ] man and
he goes it's not my [ __ ] dude it's
austin's [ __ ]
that's why it is a good guy man that's a
patriot right there
that's a good guy man sharing his [ __ ]
with the world that's what we need more
people like that that's what i'm trying
to do
it's not working i'm trying to give my
cops to as many people as i can they're
just
hell yeah hans need to spread a seed out
there in austin i know
i met a chick at the club at the show
yes whoa
you mean a woman
a beautiful chicken
a chicken you have nice eggs
she has nice ovaries
did she have double d eggs
she had double these nuts in her face
that's violent oh yeah she you had your
nuts in her face
yeah was it the old before was it the
old woman cougar
yeah it was the
milf
i was just talking to a cougar
yeah the one that was stone faced the
entire show
yeah i mean you could say that she was
not really enjoying the show that much
why wasn't she enjoying the show she was
there to get some hans kim yeah she
didn't care about comedy
she wanted her she wanted to
smack my lips
with her lips which lips which side of
the lips
that's actually a thing now right would
you
a little bit people would just want to
kiss you
not too much
people are still demicons no i know
i think hey you got you got the good
immune system yeah i'm training yeah you
started it
yeah are you immune to it i started it
on kill tony
oh yeah we were all kissing and then
we accidentally
kissed a bat and then the bat kissed the
pangolin
the pangolin kissed amy oh classic
fat coven pangolin situation
it's a foursome
it's an interesting so what's your
favorite race to kiss
probably latinas
why really some of that buttery
chocolate did it taste like oh yeah
softest lipstick that's what you call
passion hans
i love latinas i don't know i've only
kissed mostly white girls
what a [ __ ] am i right
they have the most power why did you say
latinas though
because i just like the idea of them
it's an aesthetic thing it has actual
like no like there's no tangible yo
asian shout out why are you hating on
how's that different i'm not hating
emotionally like most people have like a
reader like i like latinos oh yeah
but he's like they're like latina
kissing the most so like there's got to
be something specific to latino women's
kissing tongue no
they're just better made they're like
they're perfectly cooked they're not too
dark not too pale
perfectly cooked
nice that's some buttery shiny so when
you said butter you were talking about
the skin yeah oh okay they don't use
butter
and they're cooking
yeah they use fabuloso well i for one
prefer black women so
you prefer black women riley yeah
big black women or skinny black woman
uh big bigger the better
bigger the better he prefers strangers
off the street
yo bro that was crazy last night
oh what did i miss out on
the girl last night it was just funny
how she just started walking with us and
you were like oh there's attention
there's someone who joined our group
and she's just right there like
and then y'all disappeared together yeah
dude i introduced you well she needed to
help finding her car i don't think she
would i needed help finding her [ __ ]
yeah and none of you guys found the [ __ ]
look at her vagina that night did you
get to look at her vagina uh i took her
to the i i put one of those gynecologist
things on it checked it out a little bit
no i did that what is that thing
uh speculum
speculum yeah yeah like one the thing
that like like hoist your vagina open
like uh
it's kind of like a carjack for your
vagina
it's like you gotta wind it up and [ __ ]
really
i changed it i don't know why she ran
away from me last night
she was like oh my god i like walking
with you guys but i need to help finding
my car can you help me riley can we can
we just leave them and i just need help
can you please help me
yeah yeah i got you babe let's go i'll
help you find it babe i got you i'm like
really good at finding cars yeah yeah
yeah you're gonna find our car for like
10 minutes told her that you that you
were a famous comedian
and then we never really clarified that
yeah well she never asked about it again
so i don't think she really cared
no i was like yeah did you say anything
funny
yeah like what yeah
dude just so much funny stuff bro really
yeah i was like making her i was like
laughing
only you can make us laugh well this is
a good conversation that you have there
i can only imagine you're talking about
health care in kyle rittenhouse
wow hilarious subjects
whoa
uh are you wet right now because i am
that's why bernie sanders is so hot
do you believe in faith
what happened riley so you you dude i
just i live with a girl and you leave us
for like an hour and were like what do
you go home with her and he's like
no so well she took me around to like
find her car and like she like gave me
the wrong [ __ ] attitude did you guys
hold hands
uh
no
did you touch you touched feet
what that sounds dangerous when you're
walking
that's called tripping we're driving
tripping that's called driving and
touching interlocking toes that's even
worse how'd you interlock toes like i
came on her foot in a car with you
what she got in your car
yeah we were just driving around and
stuff
and eventually we found our car so you
we and no no and i was just kind of like
oh like did you know how was
did you put your hawaii on the leg
no i should have done more uh i mean i i
i did the uh
you know i was like oh are you cold i
did the old roofie trick it didn't work
she [ __ ] threw the drink out the
window
so then
the funniest part of the night is when
we were looking for riley's car and we
were making fun of him for not getting
any [ __ ]
and it was like where's your non-pussy
getting car and then we rolled up to
riley's car and then justin's like oh
dude right that really looks like a
non-pussy getting car it really does my
car is not
[ __ ] friendly it's a kia sorrento or
something often
screams practicality yeah accountant
it screams boring you know yeah
it screams let's let's go to see
missionary sex with you
like once a week if you want kia sorento
um that's my two cents i'm always
swimming in placenta because of all the
[ __ ] i get
it's an affordable suv
no it's not even an suv
no it's a car dude he's driving it's
like a sedan it's from the 90s
it's got like a grill
it's a what do they call it that's like
it's made out of plastic
someone said the goonies are looking
great
hey [ __ ] you yeah [ __ ] you dude
okey dokey dr jones
[Laughter]
oh my god you do look like we do look
like the goons
i'm the cool one
i'm the leader look like we grew up and
we got a podcast now
goonies were a great time for us
yeah and then i really gave up on the
acting and then decided to do comedy
it's like a modern day that would have
been cool with the sand lot but they're
asian in the sound outside of the
microphones this is really sad
what
if you're you're not talking about a
garage night last night yeah that was
sad whatever dude whatever bro
i'm taking a cheesecake factory today so
shut up are you
no dude she got you good bro because
if i just like spend all of my money on
her never get laid
she's white she's mexican she probably
wants to go to a taco taco place that's
so racist
cheesecake factory that's pretty fancy
uh
i'll take her to white a white place
cracker barrel let me
denny's i'll take it for like a truck
stop bathroom and
eat her
ass
wow riley really coming in is that where
you have all your sex truck stop
bathrooms
oh well that's where i have all my glory
hole sex
see i don't think that that austin way
of thinking will get you laid in dallas
i'm just saying what trucks there are
more classy people here trying to
[ __ ] truck stops i don't think that
happens here unless you're homeless
dallas people are classy
they like jobs yeah they're they're more
into chinese restaurants
the home of the thirty thousand dollar
millionaire
i never really understood that the
thirty thousand dollar millionaire right
you don't need a lot of money to be
right wow this place is a mansion yeah
are you a mil i'm not even a millionaire
we know riley yeah
i'm more of a thirty thousand dollar
if you're a thirty thousand dude you're
rolling in it yeah that's a lot no i
mean thirty thousand dollars compared to
the thirty thousand dollar millionaire
so i'm like really i have like a hundred
dollars that jacket really wants to be
patagonia
what's wrong with colombia bro nothing i
love colombia i'm wearing a [ __ ]
costco jacket right now
yeah you [ __ ] poor piece of [ __ ]
i inherited this jacket too i didn't
even buy it this is this is this is my
answer you inherited a logoless jacket
this was a pretty good family that's so
pretty your family all looked at it and
decided that was worth keeping your
jackets the
the color of an airplane hanger yeah
thank you
that jacket makes you 20 years older
your jacket looks like a gender reveal
party
should i take it off
no don't
you should not i'll show you what i'll
get your jacket what do you got under
that jacket your jacket looks like
you're gonna go
parachuting or skydiving yeah i look
like uh
i look like i'm aerodynamic in this no
you look like you're gonna tell me about
some place i just gotta go man yeah yeah
like have you guys been to california
you look like santa's head elf
let's all go to colorado and ski into
the eternity
you look like you run over protesters
i look like i was at kyle house's house
earlier
you have the inside scoop on the astro
world tragedy
yeah i was the one being like gosh come
on
drake drake drake i know how to get
closer to the front
i can watch dude
i was like that guy's dying
that's so not chill that you're just
lying on the floor
yeah brother
you should stop sleeping at the concert
you should start
like one of the ones responsible for
killing someone in the in the astral
world concert
you look like a little child you guys
are making fun of us
well you're supposed to read the
comments dude you're [ __ ]
uh
someone said not guilty
hell yeah brother
right yeah
uh riley got got off today he got found
not guilty
for
it's a win for all the whites
everywhere yesterday
he's a child of incest
he lives in he's also a child of god so
you said that the verdict happened like
today
yeah yeah not even like an hour ago or
something like that an hour ago
do you think another round of protests
will happen tonight
definitely
they did it on youtube probably excited
man yeah no people don't have words but
you know what look honestly i get it
though if if i was if i was uh
if i saw a mexican guy up there and he
started crying the way he did and you
know let him off but i think i
here's a tip here's a tip for all the
criminals just start crying in front of
steady eddie
if he's on the jury you got to be by the
same race though and uh in order for me
to film what is your race mexicano oh
why are you saying that i wouldn't guess
that
that was what
what did you just say mexicano taco
breath that's what i say is that a bread
of coffee
i never heard that
justin hates the hispanic people
mexicano no i don't nobody does
no i don't you say mahogany kyle did
nothing wrong
there's someone right in front of justin
he'll give him a hug yeah i would
self-defense
but cal written his or whatever his name
is he his cry was really sad
i heard the people
turned out to be like pretty dude that's
how i would cry about
going
that's what they showed it as
i mean the judge wouldn't let them show
like videos of him being like man if i
if i'm an ar-15 i'd shoot those people
like 10 days before that they wouldn't
let him show that yeah i saw that video
too and then they classified his gun as
a hunting rifle because the barrel was
long
even though it was an assault rifle
was it an ar-15 yeah yeah you can buy
those so if you're
yeah and it wasn't even his gun
he's not allowed to have a assault rifle
he's not old enough right yeah but he's
allowed to have a hunting rifle
and they called it a hunting rifle and
he he was underage and he was like it
was his friends his friend bought it for
him
and he went out there to protect the
parking lot
of a city
that's 20 minutes away from him so he
went out there looking for trouble he
found it killed two people and now we're
like yeah you can do that go go to a
protest with a gun
if you shoot someone it's no no big deal
i just don't get why you want to go to a
protest with a gun there's no reason to
go to a protest with a guy why else
are you like deputized under like when
you go and you like support
because i guess he went in support of
law enforcement which makes sense like
if you care for something go i guess but
also he's ready to go to war too yeah i
know like me and my mom were talking
about yesterday she's like i raised
y'all to not go and do stupid [ __ ] and
get hurt
like so like you would never be there
because like you can be sympathetic to
any cause you want but don't go out to
somewhere where you're gonna get shot or
have to shoot somebody exactly
which is which is really i think the big
lesson here right yeah don't go
somewhere where you got to get shot you
know somebody they're assuming uh travis
yeah i mean what was he defending
starbucks like well that's the thing i'm
wondering like how does it how is it
legal that you can go and like work
that's like vigilante that's like odd
vigilante justice but then like if he's
provoked and then he protects himself
that makes sense but at the same time he
was like a situation yeah he was
threatening who the [ __ ] cares dude he's
like standing outside of a chipotle with
an ar-15 like don't break these windows
yeah
i wouldn't break those windows you're so
[ __ ] there's no point of him there
they don't need him there he's not part
of the law enforcement he's not doing
anything he shouldn't have the [ __ ]
gun right yeah that's the added thing
like so like he has the case of
self-defense but like i don't understand
how he has the right to be there
if you could just get up in someone's
face in public be like don't hit me yeah
don't hit me and then if he hits you
that's self-defense right yeah you ever
see people do that [ __ ]
of course so [ __ ] something happened
in this scene apparently like there was
a fight in this comedy scene
like a week ago hell yeah yeah wasn't
that slammed yeah someone got slammed
outside hyenas dallas
because they ran the light
[Applause]
don't run the light we should have
slammed justin essenmaker yesterday no
i'm sorry did you run the light yeah oh
i ran the light too
you're in the light and you guys started
running some red lights on the way over
here too privileged bro i feel like yeah
yeah [ __ ] you guys
why people get extra time that's just
something they need to know about slam
white comics you run the light from here
on out oh yeah and i'll include myself
in that group we were just having such a
good time it was hard to get off the
stage dude yeah that was a good crowd
yeah they were yeah
that's a really good room too dallas
comedy club
hans met his first korean fan last night
he had a sweater
right
uh he had a really hot girlfriend
yeah his girlfriend was really cool
yeah you mean flirting with you riley
did you help her find her car too she
was cool i was like
i was like just walking around does
anyone need help finding their car yeah
with a hat like that i could imagine
does it give old smiley face i'm from
austin so i know this city pretty well
that sounds like local local mentally
challenged guy legend type stuff like oh
that's just riley he's he's been around
here for years he just helps people get
to this guy asking if he could help you
find his car he can't
eddie which one's better
i think they're all pretty good
talking sponsored by body armor
body armor you do have enough on the
table to
act like you there's super left there
here
you all smoked too much
it's like listening to
literal couch potatoes
yeah they hate us i think they hate us a
lot dude is that one comment he's
probably on the couch saying that about
us i know he's probably in an office
chair yeah how is he even watching where
are you watching this at you calling us
couch potatoes where are you watching
what are you like what are you watching
while you're running like a 5k we're to
end with we're going to end with the nra
basically you want us smokes
chat disconnected tobacco uh
right there who's disconnecting
it says
cliff would be mortified haha i don't
understand why they hate us so much like
what do people want i totally agree with
you i get it riley's a little slow guys
so apparently i'm the fastest one here
credit he's very slow
jump back into that conversation why
because they're talking about it
let's just not talk about politics
yeah it says that i'm down there in the
corner again later
i got the torch
how do i try again later
i don't know i don't know i don't know
right the livestream
oh we're not connected anymore to the
wi-fi
oh we should come in fire
more energy
they always say that about us
i mean energy is nice i don't know why
they would say that about you
well i'm actually
i'm actually not that
slow right now okay you're connected
just hear that i said that i'm actually
uh uh
well apparently we should keep talking
about kyle rittenhouse because that's
like people love it
dude [ __ ] these people man
[Laughter]
i mean we're connecting now it's like
people want a surefire yeah he should
have been there and he did everything he
should have done
it's like people don't really like we
support kyle
we support kyle
is that better is that what people want
yeah let's be supportive of kyle and
then when we yeah let's take it from a
new tank
i support senseless loss of life that's
what i do
who looks at that and it's like we
should have more of that we should have
more
more puzzling death that's what we need
in this world more controversial death i
don't know i didn't have it
yeah you had in your hand oh i i gave it
to your mom when i was there last night
gave what
a little couch potato hurt my my brain
but i could see it i guess
okay i don't know what happened but
it's a big things are happening
i mean
i guess during that time it was pretty
crazy everyone was fighting with each
other everyone was politically divided
what right now for what last year during
the george floyd protests
[ __ ] was going off oh yeah
hell yeah there was like tanks in
downtown dallas oh oh you mean uh during
the
biggest event of last year yeah are you
guys talking about the astroworld
concert the tanks there yeah i heard
george floyd was at the estrella concert
whoa
holy [ __ ] that's overkill
so stoner but what's so that's so crypt
that's a new saying last night was
pretty fun
kiko was
gonna invite us to his hotel room
it was so late dude i don't know how you
guys do it i was like dude i'm done
we played super smash for a while i kept
losing a lot no i won i fell asleep
while you guys played smash bros inside
no you snorted yeah you were snoring i
was yeah i got real drunk you were on
the cusp of death the entire time we
were playing super smash bros we have
the worst sleep apnea i've ever heard of
mine dude i was sleeping on that air
mattress dude i was yeah
i started suffocating in it because the
thing i don't know
i don't know and there's cats in there
too so
it was slowly deflating the whole night
i know and then i played yeah you kept
awake you wake up and then
inflate it more
i did it once i think it works in your
favor because it's like throughout the
night as you get more and more relaxed
the bed gets more
yeah that kind of happened for real i
was lost in my [ __ ] yeah i was lost
in the bed dude i was relaxed on the
floor yeah i mean i i almost like the
concept of sleeping on air
like that do you yeah like everyone's
like oh i want to sleep on a cloud
like sleep on an air mattress well an
air mattress is not a cloud it's
definitely like [ __ ] plastic that's
hard i think a water bed will be better
than a club water bed's worse
water bed
is there one a water bed no yeah they're
[ __ ] wild they make no sense what
were they thinking have you guys ever
slept on one yeah doesn't make any sense
i've slept on a human and that's 70
waterbed it's like being on a rowboat
i've slept on pool floaties
yeah
a pool full he's like an air mattress
which is
um well water bed no that just makes no
sense very stupid
you can't get comfortable on it and then
to get off the [ __ ] thing if you're
in the middle it takes about a minute to
get off because
yeah you're like trying not to break it
it's like quicksand
i gotta get off this you gotta spread
your weight evenly i always had dreams i
feel like a trapped orca when i was on a
water bed too
if you're on a boat
you're so soft i'm used to like peanut
butter i think it's this mic
it's just such a sound like a little bit
i think i'm really loud i really think
that i'm on my own channel so yeah
channel riley oh we all took our
headphones off
yeah a long time ago
for kyle rittenhouse it was yeah it was
for kyle ryden house so you guys you
guys said you're in support of him doing
what he did what did you say i said that
no most people uh supported him
really what did you do riley
i'm
politically
free kyle i'm politically indifferent
you're politically
[ __ ]
no i'm not dude i know who obama is
you're politically wearing that jacket
who's obama
he's uh
he's like the mayor or something i don't
know
i actually i'm in love with nancy pelosi
i think she's the greatest woman that
ever lived
nancy really really
i know a lot of people with me so that's
why i said that she's the most popular
politician the left and the right
adore her nancy pelosi yeah what about
aoc
aoc yeah you can watch me pee
or she's in pinpoint like aoc word
why do you hate aoc because tree you
can't [ __ ] her yeah that's that's
riley's that's my judgment on every
woman
is she hot get this away
why won't you [ __ ] me
hey my name is riley i do comedy you
want to [ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh riley that sounds great of course i'd
like to have sex with you
uh
riley how are you
a c-level comedian
you consider yourself a seat level i'm
probably a d level there you go nice b
level
b levels like shane gillis and
tony do you think shane gillis is b
level if shane gillis is b level that
puts us that well i'm like f actually i
don't even know
um
b level is like
i don't want to say anyone's name
why are we playing this game
who is this well no i
like longevity like like b level is just
like
like greg geraldo blue level's like the
third year b level's like a 30 year old
i mean i wonder what the [ __ ] does that
mean what is a level i guess is the a
level is like like already like retired
eyes like this like louis ck like bill
burr
like just like the older people
red-headed and then b levels like you're
going by older you're not going by good
bye i mean but they kind of go hand in
hand you're going by gooder
he also says vagina
do you say well say vagina you do have
an r when you say no i don't okay but
vagina
there's no r in there now you're trying
no i never would say that just casually
mr
[ __ ]
george carlin
is one of bill hicks a level top top
tier a level just throw that away
you can have this right here
there's none left she said george carlin
is put in a bomb i think if ice t
decided to stand up he'll be like a
higher level than that it'd be t level
why do you think he would be a higher
level
i don't know because i think whatever ic
got a joke about gots to be funny bro
just a man like say man like [ __ ] these
hoes man you know what i mean i don't
know get on this canoe without a picture
hilarious did you guys hear [ __ ] iced
teas hobit
[ __ ] these hoes oh my god i see you're
killing the game i know
that's what i do baby [ __ ] these hoes
hell yeah that's iced tea
hey man i'm iced tea i'm doing comedy
today man
women be like
[Laughter]
i'm iced tea
watch me on my show i got braids now
[ __ ]
dude that's what i see is that you gotta
cap it with the [ __ ] these hoes [ __ ]
these hoes man
we out here [ __ ] house it sounds like
chris tucker
no this is iced tea and more this is
iced tea
yeah i mean
hey i'm us t
hey y'all i'm iced tea
have you seen the rick and morty i'm low
t does he voice ice phosphorus p
magnesium f
father
hey what do the comments say do they
like my iced tea
uh yeah they say this guy should have
been shot by kyle right now
did it say that
oh [ __ ] you honestly i think kylo ren
house is on this chat what's up man hey
hey welcome to freedom
he's probably partying at some american
legion dude he's a w
f w i feel so bad yesterday hans gets
into town at like 6 30 like what open
mic should i hit he's like i'm gonna go
hit this vfw lounge and there was no
open mic there yeah it's like the idea
there's a bunch of veterans into a
veterans of foreign wars they're all oh
god they're all looking at me it's a tap
machine it's wearing
because it looks like i'm wearing
pajamas
you were wearing that right yeah hell
yeah to what the asian in a pajama to
the vfw home
what's uh i like how it's
veterans of foreign wars
it's for people
who served our country
to your veterans it's for the people
here that killed your people
yeah it's for all the people who think
kyle rittenhouse did nothing wrong at
all
they have a building
yeah they got a building where you can
get really cheap beer and kyle ridden
house themed party tonight at the vfw
they should have uh veterans american
flags around there yeah everything it's
byoar
they should have a veterans of domestic
wars
vw vdw and kyle rainhouse is the only
one in there him and like george
zimmerman
[Laughter]
it's just a confederate statue yeah and
that's solely
what makes a confederate what makes the
statue confederate
he did the raping did he do any
pillaging
guys bill cosby is a free man let's
let's not talk about it yes he's
innocent
yeah he's free to do whatever he wants
he's free to go to parties and hang out
with all the women
there's some woman who would still hang
out dude imagine you guys imagine
there's people out there that still
invite cosby to their party
now like currently they're like well we
should invite cosby
it's like setting a dog like a tiger
people that do the could you also
remember like could you imagine like
cosby like on stage with another like
younger comment because like hey man
no swearing and you're like but the
thing you did last night with the girls
like yeah that's different but
no swearing
his voice was like heard like imagine
them at a dinner table and [ __ ] and he's
like trying to prove a point and
everybody's like man shut the [ __ ] up
what if he comes out and he just does
dirty comedy
like really dirty comedy he's like you
know what you caught me i'm i'm the
whole [ __ ] is awesome you ever be
raping a chick
you can't get a panties off
and i was eating the poo like
in the intro he's the face that he made
he looks like a pimp
like
you ever watched the intro of the cosby
show
[Music]
there's something crazy that a couple
other comics showed me um they showed me
that bill cosby has a he has a music
career
you know are you all familiar with this
he has a what music he has albums
here's an album of covers and he did
like sergeant pepper's lonely heart club
band but it's like bill cosby's saying
he's like sword [ __ ] he's like i can't
do it right now but won't we watch club
band
he does the whole thing he does the
whole thing like the whole thing and
then there's like women
there's like women singing in the
background and you're just like can't
help but speak he's like yeah i'm sick
and sleepy can you see can you sing for
us like give us a little taste of it
that's so weird that just proves that
darndest thing cosby right
listen here kid is like just letting
them in like we're letting
cosby in kids minds just being like
you know he wrote a book called love and
herder's known for sweaters
yeah literally i found that book uh
cosby and it said uh he wrote it
about love in his marriage
makes it the btk killer worked at a
church
yeah yeah did he the burger king killer
fine batman
yeah the king the creepy he's like he's
like
he's like oh i'll have it my way
the edm killing imagine that guy you
like you just wake up and it's the king
[ __ ]
ready to kill you that'd be terrifying
well yeah that guy is scary as [ __ ] like
he already looks like a criminal with
that mask
yeah
he also looks like a king
well yeah he looks like a like a a guy
from the purge
yeah he also looks like a king he looks
like conor mcgregor right
yeah he kind of looks like a if a king
he worked
like a goddamn castle and he liked
burgers and then he made a fast food red
chain
his shorts are so short
he's got like short shorts yeah he's
ready to run he's a king that like needs
to go he has nice shoes
he kind of looks like a king
shut the [ __ ] up
i'm so lost right now we're talking
about the king from burger king
that was still the situation we were
talking i mean i think it's a better
mascot than a clown yeah i was just
thinking he had a video game xbox made a
video game for him yeah i remember that
i think i played burger king it was half
bad either
yeah
it was like you got it for free like a
mil or something like that
but btk stands for buying torture kill
it stands for binary trans also known as
the number two i'll take a number
the number two it
get it
i was trying to say like a burger king
reference again a whopper
the number two is the number one
yeah if you knew her would that be okay
at a whopper
like that makes like a friendly wob it's
like a whopper
what do you like more dude mcdonald's or
burger king
i like uh
um i like mcdonald's
over burger king yeah
why
because uh
i don't you know
consider myself a king so
why would i eat like a king
i'm just a peasant
oh
but they're the golden i also support
china so
wow i didn't expect that answer to go so
depressing
uh aren't we a bunch of couch potatoes
we're just all
what are the comments saying now riley
they said do a
a rave what's that long one do you want
to read riley do i need to help you read
i mean it's mostly just [ __ ]
those are letters
he's avoiding reading right now he
really is yeah it's been too fast
by the time sounds done reading it it's
all the way at the top of the screen ha
ha ha ha ha ha ha r r r r
i'm just surprised that they have good
enough internet in rvs and outside to
stream podcasts which y'all using
hans kim killed don lewis and framed
carol baskin it's
20-21 what the heck
it's the only thing i can read
hey you want to switch riley
uh
sure that way you can
read translucent i kind of like it here
though i kind of like it here but you're
so white oh you want to be you want no
you sit over here and then eddie can sit
why are we okay because like you're
white
and eddie
is dark
yeah
is this like well now i'm more than we
kill triple this is perfect we should
have done this
eddie's like the same color why why does
it make it any different because we can
see you we could see yeah but now we can
also see eddie but when eddie was
sitting there it looked like no one was
there it was like yeah
oh yeah you can see eddie now hey eddie
welcome to the show what's funny is
riley hey what's up everybody
i uh yeah riley
he's diffusing the light for us he's
like a light diffuser
he's uh he's like the moon he just
reflects yeah i'm at a full eclipse
right now i'm
full chub right now
full chub
hey did you get uh hey did you get
anywhere of a chub last night with that
girl
uh yeah hey dude she's not that chubby
okay jesus did you get her instagram
uh i got her
um patreon
really
you got her dna in your front door only
fans
you got her tina uh
did she try to give you a handy in the
car dude
no bro it was very so sad about it
man i just met her for like 10 minutes
and she didn't give me a hand
how did you find your car
somebody comment formula one racist
what like i think they're making a
statement more like formula one that
sucks we're the fastest
the speed of uh
somebody said i read good
racism uncle albert wait a sec you guys
put eddie over there to read yeah hell
yeah dude you put the smart one over
there
dude i am the smart one
oh yeah he is smarter than me
eddie is almost as slow as riley yeah
yeah no that's why
smarter than me for sure
i'm [ __ ] dumb better than what i
actually read at a floyd mayweather
shower yet great level
that's why riley is going trying so hard
we haven't showered yet tennis
it says focus your camera hans doesn't
see race
focus your cameras fellas
you want me to do that
talk about kyle right and have some art
what are we pixelated
let's talk about uh
yeah run the show riley go go what's
let's run a different angle on kyle
rittenhouse let's all swap out i'm gonna
zoom in on my balls
uh
yeah
that's how you do it you zoom in let's
talk about
isis
say kyle's an american hero
well i'll tell you that
i mean i mean any idiot we're telling
you doing hats right now and there was a
guy named trent everyone's got a hat
everyone's got a hat on
i look like i'm shooting a documentary
on vapes
[ __ ] yeah you look like this does
look like a vice channel like the guys
that started vapes hey everybody we are
in the soft white underbelly of america
with
kim riley gilmore eddie trevino and
justin
look i just want to say to everyone
tuning in i know i'm the only mexican uh
i really i'm really trying hard to
relate to these weird ass austin i would
say white guys plus white americans but
uh
detached why should your garage in your
backyard
bro
no this is not like guys
for real okay
seriously did any of you guys realize
this is happening last night we kind of
like
clapped and saw what they already were
like [ __ ] on white people yeah that
was a good moment
that's my crown my crowd hates america
oh yeah
just kidding
wait what charity is this for again
no our bank accounts charity.com so i'm
napping to the computer bro
uh
uh let's let's do this as a gofundme for
kyle written house
all proceeds go to kyle rittenhouse but
we'll keep all the money and his legal
please donate to kyle wright house
defense fund
even though he already won we just kind
of went out we want to really more money
live free
hey you commit a crime
kinda
that he killed how many two people and
then shot the arm off another dude he
shot an army he like murdered i think he
like ate a baby and
he is a baby
you think his parents are trying to
convince him to get back out there like
you just gotta you gotta get out there
man
get out on the street you gotta get back
into sports we need to see you in two
extracurriculars matt gates is like i'm
gonna hire him as an entrepreneur
school the next day for that guy yeah
hey kyle saw yeah
how's that how's everything going
saw the news
katie will you go to prom with me
don't let me get in the way of you and
private
property am i am i on private property
now am i good are you going to shoot me
yeah he's like he's like driving with
his friends he's like oh hey
he's going to go to college he's going
to [ __ ] himself at some party like that
one girl did with the assault rifle
booboo bennett yeah and then then that's
going to be his legacy he's going to be
a people what's boo-boo bennett caitlyn
bennett is like this right-wing uh
loud
thanks man i'm sorry
uh
is this right-wing like hot girl she
goes around interviewing people
she's like what do you think about gun
control
did you know that most rapists
have guns
this is the most animated i've ever seen
really did you know that most rapists
have
guns she'll try to own people on the
street
with conservative
i
haven't had sex with anyone oh wait
that's a conservative mindset the most
rapist and there's also
there's also videos of people
confronting her and they're like did you
really [ __ ] yourself at that party and
then she's a picture of her and it's not
just a little bit it's like like a long
indian braid of [ __ ] and she's wearing
white i gotta do cut offs
like she's wearing a thong
it's like a play-doh
machine there's like a split in the [ __ ]
and this girl is like a famous uh
interviewer poop
uh she's trying to be
she's got like i would say 400 000
subscribers that's a lot so is that the
secret man to making it just
[ __ ] on yourself can she interview
us
yeah she's a b-list comedian
is she
um she could probably sell out some
clubs how many subscribers does caitlin
bennett have you're invited to the chat
dude caleb
well it's it's pretty hard to find the
photo now kim bennett we have some ideas
yeah you ever heard of uh two girls one
cup
let's do it uh but you can see where the
pooh is oh
oh
oh that's a lot girl kate
hey kate so did you feel lighter after
um i know that girl yeah she do yeah she
[ __ ] in my
bed once you took her to her car and she
pooped in your seat
eddie you're still trying to read them
somebody said that hans
there's a lot of nonsense but right now
somebody helped this is that hans hates
alex jones i'm a guest
by uh dude named riley apparently uh
let's go can you just read what they say
and not your interpretation of it okay
yeah i got it he's like i would try but
there's a couple words in here i can't
sort of this one's sort of a metaphor
this one yeah this is next
it says joe likes alex so hans like alex
talk about
oh [ __ ] that what i don't even know how
to say the name maxwell that girl's on
trial with the jeffrey f james lane
the hell is that that's been going on
so what's what's the latest on that
cause i don't think i've heard anything
she's like blue blood hot she give me
blue balls
she's like a rich hamptons come here i
made you some lemons oh yeah dude
there's like she's flirting with you
with like a power flirt she spanx shoes
she thinks it's funny he puts roofies in
like you're like hard shelter who
jeffrey
is like his best friend oh that weird
looking [ __ ] yeah with the short hair
the one that's [ __ ] like the one who
looks exactly like jeffrey epstein
she looks like yeah the devil am i loud
should i turn it down no you're fine
i think i think he's like right there is
good also you know maybe the headphones
your headphones are really i mean you're
allowed headphones i am yeah just
because you can't hear yourself you're
just talking loud and like it would
appeal
everyone sounds pretty good so far
occasionally justin goes over the limit
but it's good eddie trevino
why don't i don't do that at all
justin's in the moment he's a very blue
collar man
he's a detroit
yeah he doesn't understand the these
fancy smartphones what oh yeah i took
the headphones off because we all took
him off he this i want the headphones to
keep killing sure he's like a programmer
yeah this is real look at his i made
that flannel
flannel than the champion you just look
blue collar you look like you should be
part of the uaw
uh yeah dude that was a good reference
from the 90s
yeah
i was actually referencing uh but that's
awesome
you're a good human what do you mean
i don't know how it stands for pogs how
does pog stand for the pogs is again fat
ass white girl pogs yeah pogs is also
like a little champion i think like you
little chain i don't know i don't know
pogba's again nerd thing yeah
yeah they're little things and you spank
you spin what the [ __ ]
what is sausage fest you wish you were
here huh
yeah
it's not our fault women don't try hard
canadian tuxedo sexy paps
appreciate that thank you taco jones
is better than taco bell
what the hell is
[Music]
how do we all suck at reading pog is a
game dear god
uh
am i being kyle getting away from from
murder i love granny hog is a drink
i wished lube it up
who doesn't like sausages any plans for
tonight yeah we're going to yeah we're
live
some sausages to go back door you're
going to back door where are you going
what did you think when you heard that
was your first thought what's back door
it's a comedy backdoor comedy club
what's going on there it's in richardson
they have a they have like a weekend
show
linda stogner the the infamous lyndon
it used to be ran out of like a hotel
and then now
yeah i'm going over to plano house of
comedy rocky del davis and tony are
going to be there
hitchcock really or casino they see us
and what i think is on that show plano
house of comedy that sounds far
it is
every like i told you everything in dfw
is like 30 minutes away
what time is it yogurt
uh i don't i'm sure they're doing it
early in late any dallas comedians
please let us know what are you uh
he's a genie he's a mexican genie oh
yeah
mexican genie gives you three wishes
they're all tacos
is it the shirts
i said i want a vodka here's a taco he
gives you a three dollars yeah that's a
type of taco gives you a three combo
wish
yeah i can do a cheeseburger with that
and
he gives you three wishes they're all
children
oh yeah they're all boodles and one of
them
[Music]
you guys look like i just said a clan of
cousins yeah got together in the garage
definitely
very confederate right now
yeah
riley you were in part of the group
january 6 was a hell of a because we all
look white
oh no no i'm not in that group
january 6th no no
street we're like street guys you know
yeah like street we're like we're
gangsters we're like style like streets
you look like a guy a woman could do
that was like
it's back in the 80s
oh that's just riley local the local let
me find the weakest person in the group
local handicapped man he's very friendly
that's not true though you know that's
not true and you guys are just jealous
like first impression of a woman seeing
y'all was like oh yeah he shot he
probably shops at a thrift store
yeah
no riley doesn't have to have like first
store his parents still buy his clothes
dude so yeah so what i asked for a
jacket for christmas i don't give a [ __ ]
i was right
you know what bro he's the kind of guy
that would buy his dad's towels as a
birthday gift yeah i did buy my dad
towels and you know what he loved those
towels you oh whoa
now we have something to do
he uses it every day what kind of towels
one towel you bought them one good towel
i don't know they're like 400 cr thread
or i don't know how much were they
five dollars
what
was it for his birthday
yeah and you bought him one you bought
him a couple towels i bought him a set
of towels a set of towels so we got a
set of two hands he got like he got like
nine towels
and were they nice we probably won't win
the race but we can
like a weird part of his day surprise
you can be dry and that is like an
underrated part of like like a towel
exactly having a nice yeah so it's like
it's underrated little thing i i don't
have enough money to get him like a big
thing
but like i'll get him
i know this gift isn't going to do much
for you life by a little you know it's
the little things that count dude you
should see his towels they're like so
raggedy they're like there's this is
literally a curb you're enthusiastic it
looks like a [ __ ]
this is the latest you realize most
people wouldn't be thrilled with towels
if it was like a big birthday and it was
like leonardo dicaprio
i mean what do you what do you want me
to do get him like a helicopter yeah
like a toy race car two complete
opposites you can get him like a little
drone or something you know what
you know what's a good gift
get him some cologne man what no what's
the importance did you wrap it up did
you wrap the towels or did you just hand
them out riley no i i asked them
in the amazon factory to wrap it and
they do a nice job
they put a little card for you she rolls
you paid like i love you dad so even
even the asian kids in the factory were
like wow someone's gifting towels
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
this piece of [ __ ] dude how is that not
like a that's a good gift man
no it's not a good guy oh my god would
you be excited to get towels i got i got
towels what's the thought in that
giveaway reenact
would you be excited
to wipe his
well it took him like a week to open it
so oh does he have like
parkinson's or something no i think he
just forgot i think she was like oh i
thought it was i didn't even see it
yeah i am because i would love towels as
a gift no just the fact that i guess i'm
the only one
i guess i'm the only one around here who
appreciates towels i don't
did it
he's uh 70.
that was his 70th birthday i got it oh
my god you don't have generations of
towels you should have generations of
towels
like thousands 70 towels for his 70th
birthday dead 70's like what the hell do
i need these for
i already have towels maybe you could
have got me something fun no he needs a
lot his balls are longer so he needs
like longer handcloths maybe she has
nice boxers then
to hold the balls in yeah
maybe we should have gotten some viagra
actually yeah underwear is good see like
these little kills it's literally like
like like when i changed up my underwear
to this like
new
renaissance under type of underwear like
says there's still no wi-fi it's a it's
a really
are we not on right now no it's
recording
you should see hans handling his laptop
it changes it changes the game a lot
dude you look like
like uh
like this this is how they explain that
i get your sentiment i can i like a good
set of towels too but dude like the
thing is like having an ashtray that's a
little thing but like it's so useful in
certain in a little tiny i would rather
you get me an ashtray though that makes
sense because there's novelty to that
but a set of towels is like usually
shower every day i'm happy you wash your
[ __ ] balls dad
yeah so dude i'm saying you should see
his towels they're disgusting
i like i
i look for something that people like
won't actually buy this is crazy this is
the exact okay so do you watch curb your
enthusiasm this is the exact the latest
episode they had this exact same
conversation
oh yeah i saw that episode yeah yeah
you know what hold on
it's like sometimes i like an old towel
you guys disagree with me for some
reason no we'll see like if someone that
you knew that that didn't wear deodorant
all you know and they were always musty
and you'll get them deodorant for a gift
here's some nail clippers you don't clip
your nails i got you this 50 pack of two
blade razors
i would understand because that's kind
of funny it's a novelty oh are you
[ __ ] kidding me dude that's the same
no that's the thing i would never get
that's the exact same thing
but everyone has towels not everyone has
a bidet hey dad here's some irish
springs
i love you no not it dude but i'm saying
the towels he has are not
good towels
yeah i mean you can change his tires too
do they have holes in them change out
his luggage yes they have holes in there
okay that's a bad towel yes you can
literally stick your head together can
be discolored towels can be even a
little rough
but towels cannot have holes in them
that's that's yeah your dad needs some
new toasters oh
but you should have just get them you
should just get them towels but yeah i
don't know like not as a gift no it's
like hey here we go
i just got hit up by a guy he said i had
a couple drop off for a show tonight at
tufts brewery in mckinney tonight you
interested mckinney yeah i want to do
that ask him if he needs a new towel ask
him if he needs six comics to go
six comics to do just five kiko's doing
some spanish show are
is it live anymore yeah
oh hello
comment where in the world you guys are
funny thanks for the laugh by the way
next time bring
a trash chan and a couple cats and you
have a party
what the hell is a tran tran i think so
you know what's funny is like i keep
losing all the viewers because the
internet goes out and then i start over
but i'm recording it so i'm just gonna
put it out online but it sucks because
then we could have had more viewers that
sucks uh too bad
phil what's wrong with your wi-fi
i don't know it looks like it says it's
doing really good right now though it's
too really good can you pull it up on
your phone
it says it's working he said you have
green connection i know yeah but i just
want to see what it looks like with how
many viewers we have if it's even going
out you want to pull up your stream yeah
just look it up online see what it looks
like
someone commented
red house not guilty
[Laughter]
that's a russian troll that's got to be
a russian bot right
100 no one is truly just like
at work eating their [ __ ] is their
that's
audience
one guy i'm sorry i don't know but if
it's like all you can muster is this the
thing is this a casting couch thing i
don't like it's going well what's up
from l.a 27 so far shout out epstein
still stay the course best of luck
how do you go to just use your iphone
hotspot will ya they like alex it's
probably like a local restaurant
denver colorado's in the house
just use your iphone hotspot san diego
in the house oh we're not using our
denver san diego hell yeah denver san
diego
tanner san diego that's the my open
sound city
that's the mile high beach you've been
to san diego right hans yeah yeah did
you do mad house
yeah yeah was it fun yeah it's such a
weird room
yeah it is a weird room it's a weird
house
you ever sat down
huh did you meet tim hill over there do
you know him probably
yeah
where are you going
all right bye eddie uh yeah pick up your
uh you gotta go pick up your kids from
soccer practice
does anybody have a company that wants
to sponsor us
yeah sound off in the comments if you
want to sponsor us
shout out to insalito tequila
um
chattanooga tennessee
can't wait to be anywhere else do you
guys know we'll leave move i was in
chattanooga recently yeah how was it
jeff uh [ __ ] greenspan has a show there
he has like a denmark in the house joe
rogan of
chattanooga chad twitter just taken in
the house that are like lightning bolts
you know that's like big news uh-huh the
first one is jerry finds kyle
rittenhouse not guilty of all charges in
kenosha
right
libs pissed
san diego community shows are weird
because it's a military tax yeah
huh so like see the cdc advisors
committee approves modernity and pfizer
cove boosters for all so it's like
they're like both people can be happy
yeah yeah wait they're making everybody
get one they're soft and hey i know kyle
renthouse got off but yeah everyone's
gonna get vaccines now
we should all go against boosters today
booster party he only has the one paid
spot left but he can always do a guest
spot or two and they will get some beers
yeah i mean can he do five yeah that's
the thing i don't think i could get five
one paid spot for four seconds i mean i
can kill one page
i'll still go check it out
yeah you can take the paid spot and
we'll take why is there a wheelchair in
here i just he said one or two
and they were what about three
three is just one more than two we
should all just show up and see dallas
in the house
just text him i thought we were going to
the kyle ridden house riot we're going
to the party we'll figure this out later
on on the podcast dude
who's red band here and if you say to me
i swear to god it's a denim jacket
you're the only one with a dinner red
ben is definitely phillip yeah right
yeah
oh but you're like michael goodman
you're not like unhealthy fat you're
like sup you're big boned
cravings
but i do have a little leg man
a little leg i do because i was born
yeah wait somebody just said is tony
jealous of jeremiah getting the joker
did jeremiah land a joker role
he's uh doing the cartoons
practical jokers
uh
is he really doing the voice of the
joker on something yeah that's good good
for him
yeah i mean that's cool but it's not
like really that artistically fulfilling
i would think
the joker dude that's a pretty artistic
role i feel like oh everyone does the
joker it's like doing catcher in the
rock
oh my god
dude the joker's so played out batman's
played out there's like seven batman
it's not like creative at all but like
the joker is at least like a character
batman's brooding he has depression for
days when batman shows up batman's
impressions
he feels more than you
does he yes does he yes he's like oh the
people where is
no you guys are really hurting my
feelings
i'm gonna go [ __ ] kill some clowns
you're crying
that's why he has that mask
yeah
i want a divorce
can you take off your outfit first when
you say that i want to see your face i'm
not taking it off
divorce you never listen to me
cause you're always yelling
someone also said stop talking about
states i want to hear red band talk
[Laughter]
get off your mouth dude i know i'm not
i'm not red man
i'm philip garcia you
the internet they're always trying to
make fun of you because that's the
funniest thing they can say flame my ass
up right now hey i'll find your ass
did you guys see this one
i like riley i feel like after some time
he could master the podcast thing and be
super funny
oh
he's 23. that's that girl she found you
on youtube
she's like i know he's not good right
now but eventually he'll get funny yeah
we're going to cheesecake later he's
going to find his voice just like he
found his that lady's car who commented
that my dad that's my favorite open mic
special you know your dad doesn't know
he's after a set somewhere
in a couple years
he'll be pretty nice keep at it
you're doing great just need more tarps
how many years have you have you been
doing this the molly guy on stage is
like reading jokes from facebook
that's the guy are you still talking
about me no can you stop touching the
share microphone no we wouldn't be
talking about you because you couldn't
read the jokes off facebook
dude i'm a [ __ ] joker man i just got
the joker roll
you're joking i just got a call from my
agent i landed the joker
i think the joke pulls up some lines
uh hey hans what's your favorite book
besides catcher in the rye
sex at dawn by christopher ryan
hey eddie i'd ask you i didn't know this
book is
no it's a book for sexual beings like
myself
sexual beings i'm pretty sure sexual
beings don't read books all of what's
your pronoun filled with like dirty
novels uh
yes my pronouns are
king and calm
asian and [ __ ]
my pronouns are fried rice
extra spicy
my porn kung pao or soy sauce general
says
my pronoun is msg
um
i don't know
we know eddie yeah
what are some white people stuff
horses horses are very i feel like
horses are pretty much
i feel like the group names are white
people stuff what's up just group names
in general group names yeah just groups
different names of groups like like kkk
or something well yeah yeah white people
we have a lot of groups yeah like like
you just yeah like uh what is it like uh
disc golfers
disc golfers
yeah that's a group really hockey no
like libertarians uh
so i have like lines from the joker
can you read it in your best joker do it
like a creative make it your own
i want to make that
okay
do you want us to look away so you can't
get really into it but like here's the
thing you guys can't laugh okay we'll
take it to the series please really
gonna give this thing like here's put
your mics down like if you guys laugh
like i think like i'll [ __ ] kill
myself i will cover my face
and this is for real like this is really
serious like this is like
you know
all right you guys ready such a method
after right there
all right shut up
evening commissioner
[Laughter]
uh start from the top again don't don't
keep going evening commissioner gordon
harvey dent never made it oh
wait no
do you know how to read a script uh do
you want to read it through real quick
so you can get this working right
now but let me actually do it all right
action
evening commissioner gordon harvey dent
never made it home the joker of course
not
gordon
what have you done within
me i was right here
who did you leave it with
your people
i don't like those you so good i
of course not
what
okay i see why you were having trouble
me i was right here who did you leave
him with your people
assuming of course that they are your
people not maroneys
is that racist does it depress you
lieutenant know how alone you are
it's pretty good that was good
i looked away and i was like that's the
joker
i mean that uh that [ __ ] scared me
man yeah that was terrifying if you
would like if you would have like played
that sound bit for someone and then like
gave them like a whole bunch of faces to
match it up
with do you think they would have picked
you
it depends on if i'm in the middle of
reading someone said don't quit your
date someone said don't quit your day
job riley whatever that is
hey i don't have a day job okay [ __ ] you
he works for hey
matter of fact so i don't have a job so
the scene is actually the joker oh okay
the joker in darkness gordon walks in
sits all right i get i get it
yeah yeah i got it because it [ __ ] me
up but you guys did it like a cartoon
i'm gonna do it like the joker yeah but
can someone can someone give him some
subtitles
i got it i got it oh he's got it
evening commissioner
oh my god gordon harvey dent never made
it home
the joker of course not there's so much
is this a joker that's what have you
done with him
[Laughter]
who did you leave him with
your people
assuming of course
that they are your people not moroni's
dude what is a mariah that sounds racist
give me something moroni's like i guess
one of the gangs
yeah he's an italian mobster does it
depress you lieutenant
to know how alone you are
this is like asmr joker this is weird
dude wow that was like that got me on
like a different level like
oh you pass it down it's the mexican
joke it tickles my ears joker homes
never made it home
harvard
the joker racist joker gordon what have
you done with him
me oh you're the you're reading the
joker yeah that's this is i'm taking it
i thought you were leading forrest gump
what
evening commissioner gordon
harvey dennis
that sounds like simple jack
simple jack
i like simple dude what if you were like
simple that was like [ __ ] but like
so you can't really get that mad at him
oh
that's his super powers that'd be like a
riley gilmore superhero it's like oh oh
that's cute
like oh it's teach riley he's trying
he's trying to steal the money help him
out isn't that kyle
yeah dude what if he got like a bugged
by like a [ __ ] guy like or what if
he got shot at a protest by a [ __ ]
guy
that'd be so depressing
[Music]
he thought the trigger was the safety
come on guys he's slow yeah i feel like
you know be like oh yeah like he's
probably you know like most people run a
like he doesn't really get that much
money from people so you know i might
just help him out like
i don't know um are we actually did this
really happen are you gonna be a villain
you sound like this is gonna drop the
money
can someone help me
is your mic on yeah it's
yeah it's the one that's not connected
uh
riley you look like you're gonna be
really excited about your riding lawn
mower in like 15 years
yeah bro honestly i would love to ride a
lawn mower
i can imagine like doing this you know
tom hanks stands and forwards like this
and he's like sipping over here in his
garage and he's like slapping
this thing
he's going to be with a girl that
actually buys him tiles as a gift
that's hot
dude that's just sexy
hey riley what kind of gifts do you like
uh like easy mac or something like a
couple like a couple cases
i like like what i think about gifts is
i i think you should get something that
like you wouldn't you wouldn't buy you
wouldn't go out of the way to buy for
yourself so it's like an extra add-on so
you don't go buy time for yourself you
only get a message but like it's
something like you want that you
that you wouldn't get go out of your way
to get you know like tampons
hey mom got you some tampons i know
you're i know it's about to be your week
my mom's on
happy happy birthday all your all your
old tampons have holes in them so i got
you these new ones
hey mom here i got you some mothballs
it's happy birthday
i know you want to get rid of the
spiders in your closet you never want to
go out of the way to buy your moth balls
so i picked you up moth balls
you know i got you some aspirin i know
you i know your brain i know you get
headaches sometimes she doesn't use
aspirin so oh sorry hey mom here i got
some advil here's some toothpaste oh
toothpaste and toothbrushes well you
don't even get the toothbrushes oh my
god man i mean towels are very different
than toothpaste
so you agree there's a spectrum
like hey mom agree there's a spectrum
but mine's on the right side of the
spectrum barely riley does always give
shopping at that one aisle it's like
about 30 feet past the entrance to
walmart and right to the right yeah yeah
the clearance thing like yeah where's
clearance aisle
hey i got you some halloween candy where
can i get something
in february
yeah i found the last bag of chocolates
there's some
hey mom got you some frozen broccoli i
know you like your vegetables
happy birthday mom i got you a a
figurative lamp
look i i mean i don't know like a a gift
is a gift like it doesn't really like
what like what are you looking for
you're looking for a gift to like
completely change your life if you were
gonna get bonds a gift right now you've
been hans have been friends for a while
now what would you get him
crayons
no you don't huge paper towels
[Laughter]
bed bath and beyond gift card
i'm gonna buy them some sanitizer yeah
dude home and garden hey bro here's some
windshield fluid
[Laughter]
motor oil i would get honza steering
wheel cover that'd be nice like that's
the equivalent to buying someone like a
welcome mat
i'll get hans a waffle maker
yeah waffle maker i'm gonna hand some
air fresheners for his car i'm gonna get
him some pine trees
you know i'm gonna get hans a uh a very
strong warning
don't park on my property boy
i'm gonna get hans a re uh a wake up
call
hey bud so are you gonna launch this
alarm clock for the next month or so so
are you gonna stop playing with the
microphone i don't know what what i'm i
don't know why that's doing it again i
don't know why that's a problem it's
just fragile i don't want it to yeah
you're right you're right i don't want
to [ __ ] it up either
because i don't know
this is the type of employee meeting as
long as it doesn't
yeah
it doesn't you pick as long as it
doesn't get picked up this is why taco
bell has been closing at six and like in
most likely
we're just like all unemployed [ __ ]
clothes go do a podcast we'll make your
two beefy five layer burritos when we're
done with we'd rather podcast and
contribute to the economy
but i gotta say this podcast is a baja
blast
sponsored by
nacho chalupas
sponsored by
single moms everywhere sponsored by
amazon's deal of nine towels in one
package for the price of one towel
happy father's day
sponsored by the ar-15 the choice of
patriots everywhere with the long enough
with just a long enough barrel
it's a long barrel sponsored by
automated weapons sponsored by thinking
it was a taser sponsored by boost mobile
yeah hey we know you got your father
those towels for his birthday and
father's day is right around the corner
so why not get him this nice handy dandy
you didn't think of that before you set
it up
wash cloth it was wash cloths i [ __ ]
it up wash cloths
until you figure it out yeah don't
remember shamrock because you might get
it for your dad next okay
hey hey the camera it's a good product
man i get it i'll stick by the shamwow
yeah
what else what other products that's a
towel right uh
the marshmallow gun was cool it was
pretty efficient too um
the everlasting butt plug
we got the salt gun it doesn't dissolve
or dissolve slowly
what do you suck on it it's made out of
molly and it never goes dissolves
is that what's wrong
i'm just with you molly
you lost your molly butt plug
no it's everlasting it broke off uh
the uh
the supreme brick
i don't know
whatever dude how much did the supreme
[ __ ] uh
work out in this garage so you guys
should probably leave
there's some weights over there
hey do you want to work out
here
this person's mean dude they said
i didn't know vomit could exist as a
solid until i saw riley
thanks for
watching the thing because justin's
obsessed with online publishing the
thing is bro like they're saying vomit
because i look so new york right now
i was giving you topics phillip what
that was just
probably i had to read it uh people
vomit there's vomit all over new york
that's true
because i look so new york like
streetwear i have never played with them
that's the best part of new york it's
like
i'm really good streetwear style
i hate riley can we we all hate riley
why is everyone bagging on ryan i see
like if like like an episode of like
rick and morty when someone throws up it
like comes out as riley you know like he
was like and then like riley appears as
the character
and he's like i really have i don't know
his thought process because i'm just
really really placebo that's extremely
rude placenta i mean
uh
hey guys can we make fun of justin
justin's just directing it at riley
because usually he's like tell extra why
do you have to say this every time
because every conversation is funny you
bring it up every conversation
is that not the funniest roast it's not
funny do you look like an extra jaws a
hammerhead shark
he looks like a shark tail extra taco
shark tail extra yeah like his face is
sort of like
very square
and his eyes are like really big and
wide set wide apart
like you can't be out in public and have
like a stare for like you just like like
you should have an accent because you
look creepy as [ __ ] eddie looks like he
wears a tether
i don't even know what that is bro a
tether a strap-on tether like from your
house like every like you have to be
have you guys seen this justin's had a
a dui so he knows what that is
yeah just unless he always says handy
dandy handy-dandy looks like he would uh
put a leash
looks like he says extra cheese for
everything
bring me ranch i don't even ask for it
yes
you look like a bible salesman from
brother
is it the hat
no
it's your gentility you do look like a
supervisor
your whole outfit matches except
you're like the same
we're not like the same
more man
that's what jamaicans say when they want
more
mormon
where are you going mormon more
more man mormon
uh can i get a red stripe i actually you
know i went to jamaica and it's really
not that cool
raided on a scale of poverty because
there was no white people there or what
he said written well riley that's really
racist turns out you're doing this
to the caribbean white people
you know how columbus raped a bunch of
people there i mean jamaica isn't even
supposed to be black it's supposed to be
native american but they put a bunch of
slaves there
really that's what happened jamaica's in
the middle of the caribbean
yeah i thought they were black there no
they're they're caribbean they're brown
yeah
but they put slaves there and they're
another kyle sees color hans
that's good so you're saying i need to
go to jamaica to have what i need
blacks
to shoot everyone what well look how
many blm protesters are in jamaica
but at least they're all gay
they're gay because their flag is
rainbow
who's flying no it's not i guess it's
not just
it's yellow green and black that's most
of the rainbow though if justin knows
that and you don't that's pretty bad
yeah that's pretty badass grinton house
is moving to jamaica
he's not welcome below the equator who
isn't in rittenhouse he's not yeah
why i think the pope says i think we
need more of those people he hates all
those people he hates him how does he
hate all those people guys because he
shot white people that were trying to
protect what if he just goes on a
killing spree and he's like no it's
self-defense
he's like the ultimate all right serial
killer
look at phil
i'm thinking about how unfortunate it is
that it's gonna trap
this he's 17
yeah like that
in some way it's going to trap his
mindset a little part of it if maybe if
he goes on he gets like helping you but
he's going to trap him
i was just thinking like you know that
dude's going to be 40 and if he's going
to play his entire life
you know how like you you gave her that
thought like like what his future is
going to be like yeah but like no one
thinks about like those little mexican
kids and cages and what that's going to
do to their future how much authority
like they're not they're going to hit
with their biggers
i saw this
just going to [ __ ] them up bro i saw
this bad white people
white people but written houses
yeah he's a breakout volunteer
everyone's [ __ ] up wait why do you
want these kids out of these cages eddie
because that's not where kids should be
like for their men it's like a dog they
like it people shouldn't be in cages
something
i saw this documentary about this
mexican kid who was in a cage and their
mom couldn't get him out for the longest
time they got him out and when he came
back he'd be like no touching
no touching
whoa because that's what they were
saying like don't touch each other oh
wait the mom said that no the kid the
kid's five years old he comes out of the
[ __ ] cages
oh he's just repeating what so
that's how adults talk to him
for like a year of his life that's what
he thinks language is i'm just saying
like imagine if the kids were white
and uh you saw them crying how are you
gonna feel about it how you gonna feel
about a white baby crying that took so
long well you can see the tears is here
i don't even know
it's not actually the opposite it means
we're going to have a pretty a
productive generation
they're going to be terrorists and
they're going to bring down america
easily here's the here's the solution to
kids and cages we put every kid in cages
no matter the race
that way we all have the same thing
for every mexican kid we put in a cage
we go to the suburbs pick up a white kid
we'll make them play instruments in
riley's words we get a whole jamaican
flag honestly we have kids
we put them in the kitchen oh yellow
greens
dude kids would like being in cages they
get to play with like their ipad and
[ __ ] they can do monkey bars on their
kids
like the mexican kids still get the
metal cages but like the white kids like
here you go it's like a padded room you
guys are literally mexican about that
movie us or whatever the mexican kids
get like e-network and like the white
kids get like
cnn or
i thought you wanted all that the same
childhood so they should get all the
same stuff no well i mean we have to
draw the line somewhere but honestly if
they trekked across the mexican desert
to try to cross illegally
like they've already seen a lot of [ __ ]
like they're already [ __ ] up yeah
imagine your parents saying that you're
going on all the cactuses they saw
being on a forced march you want to
march through the desert you would burst
into flames but if you're a mexican
well they're trained for that they're
trained for that they're five years old
they've been through their whole life
stop dropping roll classes in
kindergarten
you would have been helping me with a
little
i mean uh yeah [ __ ] cancel me put me
in the desert with
a lone cactus why would they separate
from parents that makes absolutely no
sense because they have to go to jail
for that to be a solution
parents have to go to jail yeah because
they try to cross illegally
that's nonsense
yeah i mean just send them back let them
try again
because then they'll try again
well then you build the wall and then
it's solved so you let everybody go back
and then the walls built that's such a
medieval thought but if but but if they
go back
if they send them back if they were like
in an actual dangerous situation you're
just basically killing them
but not if you send them back to mexico
well like what do we do
oh okay what do we do with the kids when
our parents we should just do like
a foster system right right so why
didn't we put but we didn't have the
foster system
afghanistan afghanistan they were cool
though the people they were falling off
i mean i think anybody should be able to
come in this country if they're cool
like if they're lame like don't let them
in right now
that's so funny you say that because i
have a friend from high school that's
like all hell bent on we need to find
these refugees from afghanistan homes
meanwhile we have like
children's cages at the border exactly
you're right like why why aren't they
giving like uh eddie's brain dude
because the people that run this country
are lame shouldn't ronald really need to
do something about this
and they think cool people are actually
lame when they're actually cool
that's not like yeah that's what he's
about to run a country
is yeah you too
president
i don't want you this is riley at the
border y'all were too legit dude
i don't like their vibes right now
but if you're not hot you're not in dude
yeah bring chicks
it's like it's a twenty dollar cover to
get into america right now do you know
where your car is
your pool ratios we [ __ ] the latin
american countries up so hard
now they're all coming up because this
is where all the loot is stored if we
really want to fix immigration stop
nafta stop trading with mexico stop
giving them like our corn and fruit and
let them [ __ ] grow their own [ __ ]
well then they can sell with each other
when they started the trade when they
started the first trade uh
i guess when they when they ended that
trade when they started i think they did
it for a couple years it kind of ruined
mexico's economy like right away yeah i
mean it's there's going to be a growing
period but
also when you're used when you when any
kind of economy or any person even gets
used to like just being given things
they lose they
they adapt to the ability they adapt to
lose the ability to provide for
themselves that's right
also it's just corrupted as [ __ ] yeah
they don't have they don't have the
the new president is completely
compromised just using mexico to sell
more walmart goods the cia is using them
to produce drugs make their own [ __ ]
anything they make would be
more expensive than the [ __ ] that
walmart i mean there's still stuff they
trade i mean avocados and right
right
but their economy is ruined ever since
nafta and that's when the drug trade
started because they can sell us drugs
and now they're giving us fentanyl and
they're killing us
the mexicans are yeah they get the
ingredients from
china and they go get into mexico and
the mexicans make it and then we have
free trade
i don't think mexico would ever put
fentanyl in their in their product i
think that's like no they sell it
they're
importing tons of fentanyl every day i
asked someone why the other day why it's
even being cut into cocaine because they
seem like completely opposite drugs
right i mean coke is an upper in
fentanyl that's why it's fun to do once
and all is super addictive that's
awesome right but here's the someone
told me they can dilute it and then that
makes like you can also die
right
because
it's hard to get but fentanyl you can
make in a lab right so they have
snorting
diluted
numbing effect that coke might get but
you're not going to get up
i just think it's a strange thing it's
just a high like most people can't tell
exactly how what they're highlighting
test strips to make sure there's
fentanyl in it
i don't see the problem with the drug no
seriously we should be serious though
what are you saying are you two how are
you getting all right
i don't know i just don't know anything
about politics and you guys are talking
about politics and like how do they
bring the fentanyl up here in the in
their house trucks or
all the trucks that move back and forth
between america and mexico have you not
seen cheech and chong dude i was saying
i i was gonna build the truck out of it
dude those jalapeno trucks
was it like there was watermelons that
they
you see that one yeah with the
watermelon
they put drugs and fruits yeah all right
riley politics
they're down there putting drugs and
fruits
i'd open that apple i bet you it's
fitting all no drugs and fruit sign my
petition
fruits
i'm like trying to have like a political
talk with someone did you know they put
drugs you get elected on that platform
no drugs and fruit vitamin c no i want
there to be drugs
that's awesome like an edible a taste of
a fruit and a taste of what if you could
breed a grape to be having thc in it you
totally that would be dope you eat
grapes and you get high you can infuse
it
yeah get on it science it would have to
be like you know they activate it though
that's the thing about thc
it has to be decarboxylated to be able
to diabetes nerd decarboxylated
dude i love how stone i love how our
weed has just been taken over by nerds
and it's just like oh we gotta like he
we gotta make 92 points
people who smoke weed can read a book
sometimes
dude but like seriously like nerds took
over weed like it's like all like it's
here it's all like it's all like it's
all like machines and like science stuff
and like extracting and doing science
[ __ ] and it's just like dude just
[ __ ] you guys are hurting riley's
brain right now don't do that [ __ ] yeah
to be more smart you should smoke weed
to relax and not to like get more
intense yeah they're like
make it the weed
science
this is jamaica
riley did you do good in school i'm
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude
the happy place just gets more and more
meaning to it
let's get let's be serious though
seriously let's suppose
uh we need to yeah mexico have their own
economy and not just ruin their economy
to sell more walmart kids
yeah i mean i wouldn't i wouldn't mind
taking mexico under our wing
really yeah they have cool landscapes
and like it's like a pretty cool country
yeah wow landscapes and cool stuff they
got good guns they got a lot of guns
beaches and
we have alerts yeah but they're buying
texas back
really what are you talking about you
know how many you know how many you know
how much land that's gonna buy in texas
right now yeah they need to build the
walls it's insane we're buying all the
land i know that's what they're saying
about chinese people they're sending
china sending like students over with a
lot of money to infiltrate america just
start
[ __ ] [ __ ] up
just buying stuff i don't think we're
are we live that's what you were saying
about pumpkin
pong
oh [ __ ] we shouldn't [ __ ] no the the cia
uh yeah the yeah
but i don't know about the money though
buying stuff i don't know about that
maybe just like infiltrating like groups
you're so available because i had
exchange i had it like asian exchange
students and they would just spend a
[ __ ] ton of money like in a like over
here
like they would just like be always
buying clothes that's why that's where i
got my streetwear ideas from
china
yeah
from your chinese exchange students
oh yeah you told me that only none of
them were hot
yeah i mean
so
that sucks yeah it kind of sucks but
whatever
they had like weird teeth
no
were they skinny like malnourished no
they're just like like normal looking
uh
unattractive people
you don't like chinese people either no
i'm just joking like they they they're
attractive i just wasn't attracted i
mean two of them are guys that doesn't
help
i mean maybe for you it might help but
for most of us we wouldn't be into that
that's what i'm saying it's like i'm not
attracted to that i mean asian dudes are
not that hot they're usually more
effeminate and they're like weak and
yeah that's what makes them frail
but what was uh what would what are the
what on a one-to-ten scale well how hot
was the girl no let's not do this man
let's do it
no seriously though seriously
always rate women on a new miracle
that's what my mom raised me she's not
gonna see this no uh i invited her
she already knows that you don't find
her attractive i never look i never said
that you said they were attractive but
you weren't attracted did anyone else
here no i didn't hear a number so i
don't know hot shoes i don't know how
hot she is either um i'm kind of at a
loss the number is covered 19.
that's not the screen
it's only one let's be serious
why uh
why was she not that attractive look can
we just like was it like her eyes were a
little hooded oh yeah
i don't know how to explain it
does she look sickly no you do know how
to express a very healthy woman who we
talk
and honestly she is attractive you know
what she is attracted i don't know
well
you're talking riley is a chinese
exchange student and she's very have you
ever had an exchange student no
i did once but i wasn't there before i
won once i am one now
thanks for having me guys
sure you're welcome your first lesson
your first lesson about asians don't
talk about asians share our milk and
honey
uh
i didn't have sex till i was 22.
that's when i stopped 23.
you're 23 now aren't you
yeah good
last year was a good year for me yeah
how was it i had sex for the first time
how was the sex for the first time it
was
it was a lot have you ever had sex not
in a van
yeah
yeah more like uh you had one in like a
i've had sex in this school i've never
had sex you like closets i've had sex in
this garage like at least yeah i have a
sex in a broom closet
probably with five different women in
this garage
jeez dude that's [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
good for you i lived with my mom for
[ __ ] two years that's so convenient
probably during the spring or fall
because i bet it gets really hot i don't
like it yeah no no i mean one time my
car was parked in here like an extra car
at one point and i just come here and
turn that bad boy on
and then [ __ ] in the backseat you get
hot in this can't get no you open the
garage
hey baby are you ready to relax forever
we're gonna go into a deep sleep while
we fight how does that kill you
you like start caught you suffocate
because the things that come out of the
tailpipe of a car are bad for humans to
breathe
no riley that's totally good is that an
optimal way to like kill yourself it's
like a volcano man it's the best way
it's like a white like suburban mob way
to kill yourself i feel like that's not
badass i think it's a white suburban dad
way to kill yourself i mean you don't
want to be like richard jenny and shoot
yourself in the head and live for
another day
you know people used to put their head
in the oven because they were gas back
in the day they're not the same ovens
anymore it's bizarre dude
uh yeah i mean at least like i think i'd
do like a jump because that's badass you
know oh my god
but you're not guaranteed to die from a
jump if it's yeah you are there was a
case back in the day where like three
sisters all killed themselves they're
like a suicide pact i don't remember
what it was over but it was like
literally over nonsense they were just
like hee yeah we'll do that it was like
in the 60s is that what kirsten dunst i
think so there's a movie about it yeah
and uh one of them puts her head in the
oven i think one uses the car and then i
forget what the other one does but hangs
himself and then there's the sharks of
the
like shoes dangling and they're like
really pretty shoes dude yeah they're
really pretty shoes they are the
ultimate
uh did they at least go viral
how would they know if maybe it was a
new tick-tock trend
yeah hey kids killing yourself remember
pov we're definitely doing that
survivor
remember that [ __ ]
no people watching tv no pov i'm a
holocaust survivor or i'm at the
holocaust
oh yeah yeah what the [ __ ] i know but
that was you know that about that was
done in taste that was stolen valor what
was it about let's get serious it was
just like people pretending they were at
the holocaust and they were like oh i'm
a jew
that's stolen squalor
it's [ __ ] up
my name is my name is kevin smith and
this is my pov of me at the holocaust
hey i'm here at the house
oh i'm walking here we're jackass and
this is the holocaust
no food
boy am i hungry is there a place to get
a bagel around oh dude
i'm so hungry right now bro
they don't even have any reading
material
these showers are smelly man
is anybody gonna make a good roast beef
this is terrible this is this is easily
the worst thing i've done in a podcast
now i need to see a doctor
i don't feel so good
i feel kind of queasy something's wrong
they own the media we might want to be
are you jewish they're going to make
look the wind's blowing now oh [ __ ]
they're showing up right now they're
rolling up
it's a bit dusty in here
the spacing on this tattoo is terrible
who wrote who did this tattoo okay this
is
cancelled
no dude no who got canceled was hitler
let's get serious
hitler got soaked that was so dude he
didn't even what did he do
he shot himself with the walter
uh
i already was a really good guy and a
good influencer on the community i heard
he was a fun hang on yeah i heard he was
great he was a political leader he was
wearing a playpod he was a good chess
player you know he went out with a bang
he sold out stadiums
dude sold out stadium he's the first
nice clay he likes travis scott he was
nice clay before
dude
people really liked hitler's camps you
know they'd always go to his campsites
and hang out yeah he was a big camp yeah
no he had he actually also had regular
camps that weren't he was a sagittarius
and to me that's just he had regular i
heard he liked a lot of bonfires they
had a lot of big bonfires you know
uh
no i think that was the jews he was
burning
yeah that's what i meant
it was the final pollution
burn a jew
you know i think jewish people are
really great people that's what i think
i think the jews are wonderful people
and uh
i said
the worst thing hitler ever did was like
his [ __ ] geographic and footprint
yeah
climate footprint his carbon carbon
carbon footprint geographic footprint
his geographic footprint was pretty big
though he almost created the third reich
yeah true man
to russia yeah he almost like won what
is right is that's like the world
abomination but hitler what hitler was
trying to do
is what uh the europeans did to the
native people native americans yeah he's
european europeans except
someone had to it's
yeah he terminated a a
a majority of group of people
conquered them maybe
like yeah say what you will about hitler
but like do you think he had a really
small dick do you think he had a small
penis like really really small i thought
i don't know i think he was like oh i
know he had a really cool muscle but he
holds he he got some hanging
maybe he had a lot of balls huge guys
for sure
i don't know
big balls
what if hitler was trans
that would explain it all the first
trans person yeah
that would make sense why the trans
community is so well the trans-atlantic
yeah it hasn't been live for a minute
but it's been recording
but it's live right now that's what i
thought but it's not i went on to his
profile and you can't see it or anything
really thank you well keep talking i'm
recording
they probably they probably deleted your
channel after what we just said about
dude you should be allowed to say
whatever you want to say oh [ __ ] as long
as it's going red jacket makes sense
everything's coming in order no
he's not [ __ ] people he is mean just
republican and conservative are you
republican you're actually something did
you vote he says he's a republican but
everyone he voted for is all
democrats
this is my mom made me vote for them
well that's the right people to vote for
who'd you vote for i voted who'd you
vote for uh did you vote for biden or
trump i voted for biden
he voted for clinton he voted for buying
it he voted for obama oh man who am i
sitting next to those are all
republicans i thought
[Music]
i voted for if you got to pee you can
just go in the side of the oh my god if
you want you want to go
are we doing are you going inside yeah
can you put coffee in that cup
i'll bring the whole thing out okay yeah
can you get me a cup sure thanks man
hey guys now that hans is gone let's
talk with him asians huh now we have
full control over his channel
what are we gonna do we're not live
uh
but we're still waiting wait are we
partial control over his channel
everyone plug everything you have okay
uh
plug and plug all my holes
that's what we do we turn we we get
youtube banned from the internet right
now by just sticking it in every hole
riley has youtube supports every i just
want to say that youtube supports
everything we say on this podcast eddie
hold him the [ __ ] down right now i got
you okay
do you i mean do you guys he's been
talking did he hate you this is the you
know
white people it was like seems like uh
it's more like a dislike okay we are
live what the [ __ ] hey by the way we are
in hearst texas
no we're not you idiot
or in hurst texas 1701
uh gemini street gemini street my poor
mother jeez
we are live we're live right now gemini
so
all right well we're live and there's
nothing we can [ __ ] do about it okay
what do you mean
i'm just saying there's nothing we can
do about it
dude what do you mean
we're live there's nothing we can do
about it
what do you mean
whatever what's good is that we weren't
live for the part that we just went
through you know the part where we were
like yeah
let's repeat it yeah let's tell you what
you want to go you want to go back over
jews complaining at the holocaust
they were complaining why are they they
weren't complaining i mean i mean oh hey
i think they have a right to do this do
the showers line one more time jews are
allowed to complain at the holocaust if
everyone has the right to complain if
that's not why
can you act it out one more time for me
no let's not do it okay why not
because it hurt my feelings
that you
the things you said hurt your feelings
because you guys are acting like the
holocaust happened and it hurts my
feeling like i said
you know it never does it never happened
so
you guys are acting like it's i don't
know
i mean i don't know if it happened or if
it did just like the moon landing i mean
i'm a little spectacle
really what are you doing i mean i'm
just saying all i'm saying is i don't
know i know what they tell me but i
would never know no for anything
anything that happened before i was like
this is a way bigger someone said that
they're from germany oh yeah but it's
still i mean if it if it happened it
happened
you're gonna help me on the
pronunciation there says you are very
inspirational to me this is for hans hey
you're you're inspiring to some german
people uh hey he wants you to know that
our takes on the holocaust were tasteful
oh that's what he said no he said i'm
doing stand-up in germany i've done four
shows so i'm pretty sure they hate it
when you talk about the holocaust around
them thanks
the cost
do you guys know that eddie doesn't
believe in the holocaust
i didn't say i didn't believe in it
i said i don't know i don't know a lot
of
things about
moon landing though i want to know
something real quick
on the on the moon landing you say you
don't believe it but if uh i said i was
skeptical you're skeptical but if it was
a mexican that landed it on the moon
would you believe it uh i'll still be
skeptical
why
because i i don't know if it had i
wasn't there
yeah none of us were there we have to
well what'd you say they can jump that
high the jews
dude if they can climb a wall they can
make it to the moon okay hey white
people could climb the wall too they
[ __ ] climb that we don't get capital
eddie the [ __ ] capital they listen
white people on there
parkour
no the only reason we paid for the damn
capital i'm coming in there the only
reason we could climb is because they
had a ramp access
and they were doing construction on half
the building so it was like just open oh
so they were ready they were preparing
but there was something hey you know who
was like one person died because they
yeah she wasn't ready did y'all watch
the hbo documentary no i tried it sad
dude they talk about like they interview
the police officers and they talk about
how like the first line breaks right and
they just like help us they run back to
the next line and then when that goes
and they get to the point where like
they're right up to the doors and then
that's the point when officers were just
like
literally there's nothing we can do
everyone get inside the capitol and then
it's just them like playing cat and
mouse around the massive building that
they have yeah it was really stupid and
being like hey you can't do that and
then the next thing you know there's 30
other people rounding that corner and
then you just have to be like i'm
[ __ ] out there there's too many if
you have numbers there's nothing and
they were they were all told not to fire
no matter what like they're like i
thought this was a mall yeah
where's the cinnabon at
some point where's the constitution i
want to take it
where's my sample of wetzel's pretzels
i need it
i need it but my thing is
costco yeah goddamn
where's the pout of cereal what uh why
don't they just lock the doors what's
crazy is the so they take all the blocks
all of the
representatives and senators and
whatever they took them all away
right they had protection except for the
ones that were up in the rafters they're
stuck where did they put them
they take them into like a tunnel or
something but what's crazy is every
single for every single one of those
representatives they have like three
interns
who have no who the capital has no
obligation to protect so they're talking
there's these ritzy looking people in
suits who are the real workers there are
running around trying to figure out how
to the [ __ ] to get out of the mess and
they're not like
officers are like walking by them
because they're they have no obligation
to protect them they're like so they
were trying to the the people that that
charged
the capital they were trying to hurt
people or just like [ __ ] [ __ ] up in the
video
they literally didn't have a plan no
they were like we're gonna go in there
and then stop that i don't know america
will be free after that i'm gonna sit on
nancy pelosi's chair and [ __ ] up her
desk i'm gonna fart in the office i'm
gonna smell her desk chair and get the
[ __ ] out they all just wanted to do like
stupid things i'm gonna eat a honey
bunny in the honey bun in the royal
office was he like like september 11th
too the the terrorists that planned that
out but if you decided to put that plan
together that's
that's like a you like you you were in a
cave deciding to make this plan with a
box cutter how did you think it was
going to work
and it [ __ ] worked that's the i was
kept
that was their mission no no i'm talking
about september 11th but september 11
i didn't realize we switched to 911
like i'm looking at the idea of making
plans
that seem like mission impossible plan
let's go store in a capital and we'll
get away with it you know what i mean
nancy pelosi like picks up a pin and
smells it occasionally she's like
what the [ __ ] oh [ __ ] no [ __ ] oh god
damn it yeah this is one of those
another [ __ ] pen
that's another [ __ ] pen
god damn it she writes so much [ __ ]
policies it makes sense oh political way
what stated uh yeah i
a lot of people don't know this listen a
lot of people don't know this but [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
a lot of people don't know i mean the
captain i don't even really know who she
is i mean she's old and she has to get
up early she is a [ __ ] not a lot of
people know this
right like
if you try to wake up your grandma early
in the morning every day to do some [ __ ]
to cook or whatever she got to do go to
work have you seen her
she's 80. she's 80. we're ruled by a
gerontocracy everyone is like 70 or
above i don't know why they let old
people make these decisions because they
can't even change their views on the
world they're not even cool oh
minorities damn it do you know exactly
we don't want to change all of their
stock trades are public information
because they're elected officials and if
you follow like nancy pelosi's husband's
options
you'll profit basically
yeah it's crazy
it's crazy every single place you make
sure i remember the secret she bought a
ton of videos to be a politician
alphabet she bought the uh which is
google alphabet
she bought q a on
she bought qnc too it's crazy she needs
she needs to pay [ __ ] taxes
yeah she's the multiple sheridan i can't
say anything because i've never paid
taxes she needs to they always give me
money they're like oh yeah we get it
dude let's call the tax return i think
the system's working for me
yeah i mean we started reusing that tax
money like instead of talking about
abortion laws we need to figure out what
we can do to end the homeless problem or
get 35 done
where were the cops no you fig you
solved the abortion problem that solves
the homeless problem because then there
won't be so many loser babies
yeah abortion is going to be the
solution uh yeah true there's a lot of
loser babies right honestly though
we're all a lot of people
the people that are probably getting
abortions are people that probably
should be getting the abortions if
they're they're like i can't have the
baby i think
it's probably the smartest decision it's
sad it sucks and it's sad but also if
they can't if you can't provide for a
baby
what like it's better to not have it but
you're going to put the burden on
society yeah have the baby now but it's
also like it's also like i don't know if
you should take away the rights of
someone to have a baby like but why
can't you take care of your baby what's
wrong with this country where like
people can't like can't even take care
of a baby yes being immature you don't
have enough money it's just being
immature don't give a [ __ ]
having sex to have the kids i wish my
parents didn't have me we have no
economic power why are they inside of a
garbage bag
we're garbage male kids any jokes about
the written house trial
yes yeah the first hour yeah say hello
to the first half of the episode
oh no but if you want a kyle rittenhouse
joke uh
i i don't think there's any jokes to say
about it i think the kid went through a
lot of i think he went through a
traumatic experience and i really
support him and i hope he does well
after this dramatic experience has
happened and i'm glad that he's free
he's a victim of cancer culture uh i
would have to say he got lucky and wow
eddie he better he better
he better feel he better [ __ ] go to
church eddie there's a white man talking
you better to church thank you he better
go to church and and and pray talking
about right now
yeah dude
i don't even understand human nature
eddie if you get threatened you're
supposed to kill him
like shoot him right in the face
you're also just supposed to have an ar
just wherever you are it's a hunting
right that's how you protest it was a
hunting like he was killing i'm on your
side i know but you're saying ar-15 no
it was a hunting rifle he was going
hunting and then someone threatened him
he was going out to the woods and then
someone was like i'm gonna kill you so
he's like well might as well use my gun
now so yeah i support cal rittenhouse
he was hunting he was just a boy walking
he was he wasn't doing anything wrong no
he was walking he's like
down the street dark meat they said that
they want us to be funny they asked for
us to talk about cop written house that
we talked about and now they're like be
funny all right
you want me to do a song and dance too
well
who's who said that what's that guy's
name is he still on there it's like nate
conrad
nate conrad what a [ __ ] name
and uh
your last name is conrad that guy is a
good guy
oh you know who nate is i'm sure he's a
good guy he's just missing [ __ ] me yeah
he's white he's kind of douchey you know
he's probably dating a [ __ ] kimberly
hey nate you got a friend of philip
garcia dude that's all you need yeah you
got a friend of me too he's wearing a
polo sweater right now that [ __ ]
[ __ ]
nate confact
sweater so that's patagonia dude it's
colombian actually
is colombia
colombia is different
than colombian right colombia is dallas
it's the eponymom eponam min
eponym what's that of colombia eponym is
like what you call the people who are
that like
washingtonians
that's how that works
i don't have enough iron in my blood i'm
ebonic what do you mean you sound like a
a cartoon rapist bro you don't even know
what ebonics is and you don't even know
like my name is justin and uh let me
tell you that like you ever ate ass hate
ass i ate ass at a walmart that's that's
the way you said everybody voice is like
no
that was just a story i i told him when
i was with his mom the other day i was
like i was at walmart and she's like
keep my house you were with his mom yeah
yeah it was disgusting
she's interested
how many she's into trailer traps how
many people other than eddie have eaten
ass i mean i i never ate ass before
eddie you've eaten ass i swear to god on
the radar eddie has drunk eight ass at
least twice no i can't tell you no
that's that's pretty [ __ ] up
right i swear to god
you go straight for the ass no you're
just trying to normalize what you gotta
do all the [ __ ] time yeah yeah i look
like i eat that especially that what's
wrong with that you gotta eat ass teeth
put his mouth in some questionable
places yeah have you put in an ass yet
yeah definitely hell yeah i believe that
i believe your sex life has been popping
off right for real yeah kind of wild you
know with your little fame going right
what's the craziest thing uh some
woman's done or women what do they
request for you to do i've almost had a
threesome i [ __ ] it up you almost had
it you didn't have it how did you
[ __ ] have it because i didn't really
want it
i remember you talking about that too
much work or the you weren't attracted
to like one of the girls was acting
[ __ ] crazy and annoying and i was
just not attracted to her talking
constantly
like dad always says you don't need more
than a handful
who's but sometimes there's a couple
handfuls but that's like they try to be
unattractive holy towns because they
don't want to get raped so they're like
they're experts at making men not
attracted to them
and then they do it on me and i'm like
oh yeah it worked
making them not attracted to you yeah
they just want to control the sexual
attraction
women do
so they're like oh so you're like give
me my [ __ ] props all right i'm sexy
you wanted more sexy
honestly
them to find me i wanted to find them
they just wouldn't this one person
wanted to be quiet
it's like telling us long stories about
her life and it's like oh that's the
worst it's like i don't wanna hear your
[ __ ] suicidal story while we're about
to have sex yeah yeah one time i got
really dark and i was like overdosing
and then my friend saved me then i threw
i thought that was just the next day
like i like just happened you're like oh
my god this is so funny excuse me that's
how i feel about about women that talk
about like the moon all right hans did
you order uber each
i'm sorry ah
that's an asian joke that's a dog
the best part about asian food is it
comes to you
and it's fresh you kill it yourself
oh watch him you gotta get him out of
here he's gonna [ __ ] something up
that's fine
i don't want to get a wire
um
i mean
i feel like the threesome was pretty fun
um
no i didn't
what else i i [ __ ] a girl
in one hotel room and then i went to the
next hotel room and i [ __ ] another
girl that's a minute what
was better
what'd you like more it was both
damn
yeah it doesn't get sad it was really
hot how did that happen was that sad
look
so both girls were at the same hotel or
what what was that so here's how you
know what i noticed i think if you get
laid so this one girl
i knew i met in seattle when i was
living in seattle and then we hooked up
um guys yeah i guess if you're looking
for love look guys let's have one
conversation though he's about to tell
the greatest story
go for it so i was in a relationship
with this girl in seattle and then my
this girl that i used to have sex with
in new york came
to seattle and she was like hey can we
have sex and i was like yes and then i
started having sex with her
and i told the other girl and i was like
i know it's a
huge thing but i'm gonna have sex with
her and then i had sex with her
and then uh
she invited me to her friend's house
where she was staying
and i went over to a friend's house and
we were making out on their couch and i
wasn't supposed to be there and this guy
comes in to get his keys or something
and then they she catches us there and
he catches us inside and then we're
making out and then
she gets a text from a friend like can
you please leave my house and stop
making out on my couch
and she was like oh [ __ ] i was supposed
to stay here for two more nights and i
was like oh my family's staying in a
hotel right now because our carpet got
flooded so you can stay in this hotel
because my family's going back to the
house now
and so she was staying in one room of
the hotel
and then
uh it was this girl mike the girl i was
in relationships with birthday and then
so i was like come over to the hotel
have a birthday party i know there's
this other girl there
and then we went on a walk and i touched
both their butts and made out with them
around the sculpture
and then we sat down and then i was like
right next to both you're banging out
with both of them at the same time they
both know you're making out
yeah it was like one hand on each cheek
no we'd be going around the corner i'd
make out with one and then i go sink
around the other oh there's like a
freaky oh you're not together no we are
it's like this is in new york no this is
seattle seattle yeah and then she kept
talking about some like a missing
type of situation
a little bit i guess he's parting his
hair and then we're all sitting on the
couch like this
and i was like so uh you guys want to
have a threesome and then this girl over
here is like
ah [ __ ] you ruined it and then she went
into her room and then i [ __ ] this
girl in my room and then i went over and
[ __ ] this girl
and i went back to sleep with this guy
no clue
oh my god you dirty but wait so
hey i just gotta go get i gotta go to
the snack machine real quick in seattle
what did you tell her when you left to
go
i was like i'm gonna go check in on her
i just want to make sure she's not
crying or anything so that was your
girlfriend
they were in a relationship but it was
open-ended
han's a heartbreaking battle
relationship how long were you gone for
and then what happened what did you what
did you tell her when you came back when
she passed out or what she was like is
she okay and i was like yeah she's good
okay and then she's like yeah
she's like that's good
she knew
phil's doing his
for kyle rent house in 40 years
ago
crisis again
for what what happened now i was
listening oh
uh so like our asian dicks like a pez
machine where you just have like a bunch
of like little ones that you like kind
of
that's our semen
or like yeah we just shoot out solid
semen hey hans you know once you have
kids all that [ __ ] like that version of
you is dead you know that right
like it's gone you will never be that
hans again do you have a kid yeah two
boys uh
yeah i look i'm looking at y'all as like
troublemakers dude i'm sorry you're like
crazy i'm sorry i don't have i'm not i
don't know what i'm doing you never hang
out with me bro
i think eddie has well i don't know but
don't you think there's a lot of people
with kids that are swingers
oh [ __ ] maybe maybe their kids are
already grown my kids are like teenagers
right the way hans is going dude he's
gonna have two women pregnant at the
same time
i mean
sexy processes
that would be cool hell yeah it's
efficient the same thing with abortions
like go to the next room and then come
back that's a hans movie right there
you're gonna have to go that's han's
first movie like he just impregnates
like four women you call it two love
stories and it's just all happens in the
same place and they all like drop
drop the kids off with hans to figure it
out it's called planned love
i babysit one of one of them at a time
planned a and b
yeah
you'll have a black kid a little latina
kid
what happened
but he doesn't want the babies uh it's
funny because it's called planned
parenthood because it's like you go
there and be like i was actually
planning on not being a parent yeah
that's why is it
discouraging unplanned parents nothing
is like in life is planned
that's what your parents told you right
what about a blueprint they're like we
didn't plan on having this happen
we really want some towels later that's
why i was drinking the whole time you
were pregnant yeah yeah your dad your
dad busted and your mom was like i'm
gonna need thousands twenty or three
years
you better have that baby damn it we're
not aborting him probably we're gonna
get towels when i need it
am i not aborted kid's going to get me
you came and your mom was like ooh baby
that's some towels for me
roll the dice baby
we don't we don't have anything to clean
up with now but we will in 23 years
leave it all
i have six kids six towels these towels
don't even drive me riley they don't
even work they're cheap but they're nice
right they're walmart i have holes in
them
i can't believe your dad's house had
holes in him dude is he doing okay um
now he is with his new towel he's doing
fantastic how happy yeah he's like hey
ryan every time he calls his dad he's
like hey son the towels are working
great i am dry as a bone oh my god he's
like actually i dried i can't stop
rubbing myself it's just the fr i'm
getting friction burns i'm calling you
fresh out of the shower right now and
let me tell you not a tick on this body
it feels like some target tiles
[Music]
i am uh heaven i don't even wear clothes
anymore
i just live in a bath house really
what if i just like awaken something
inside of him where he's just like i
should get more just
i just come to his house there's just
towels everywhere he's wearing him like
the ghost outfit for halloween he's just
cut two of those i got two eye holes in
it
what if he had relationships with his
old towels that's why he kept him for
too long yeah but he talks yeah what if
i come over he's still using the old
towels i'm like what the [ __ ] yes and
well the other ones didn't work did you
know that
he's like i can't he got i cleaned it up
i tried to return them for store credit
they gave me two dollars i i bought a
snickers and was hanging i should call
them right now and ask them
i was gonna use the towels but then it
made me really sad about how my son
doesn't love me
dude please call your dad i was gonna
use the towels but i was afraid to get a
rash
i want to hear him
because he's got to be like yeah he got
me towels no no no no he'll back me up
he will back me up
you're your father's son he's like i
didn't even know where to get towels
from son i really appreciate it you're
not allowed to know i don't know how to
use the internet
what the [ __ ] you call
hey dad don't worry next his dad is
black i'll get you some groceries
what you want
oh man he's probably wrapped up in a
towel right about now he's probably he
is if he's right there i will probably
like i will die right now little baby
hello
hey hey dad you're on the podcast
uh let's me and my friends that just
wanted to know if you enjoyed your
towels
as a gift i got you
oh yeah that's uh they were top shelf
thank you thank you and like they're
like saying that like towels aren't a
good gift and i'm saying like you really
like them right
you really like them right what do they
do what do they use i don't know
i think they're like towels
cows are great but as a gift
but we're talking about it as a gift sir
how did you like it as a gift
what'd you say
what did you like it as a gift he said
very thoughtful
it's great
it took about two years ago when
a trash can
to use in the kitchen from you kids
from you kids you guys chipped in for a
trash can you are some trash kids
that's what i'm saying that's what i'm
trying to tell these people the gift
should be practical
but like on a regular christmas
christmas garbage can of all the things
we named we never came up with garbage
can
you woke up and you were you were what
are some other to santa under the tree
and there's just like a pack of toilet
paper
some toothbrushes
what other gifts your kids got him for
like
what are some memorable
you have a dog as a dad
can i play with the stick next can i
just yeah this christmas we're getting
you a stick
that way you can have a full game to
play i forget what the other stuff was
but it was definitely on top of towels
and trash cans
that's the name of your album dude
towels and trash cans
did they ever buy you like a shovel just
one shovel did they ever buy you a
shovel or like an ice pick or something
no he has shovels
[Laughter]
you don't have towels and like i and i
got you towels because remember your
your other towels were like so raggedy
but yeah i mean you know you're always
looking out for my hygiene number one
you gotta wait till christmas though in
the kitchen yeah
yeah yeah it's
so like i mean
i don't know what they're like expecting
like a gift should be jumper cables
hey dad do you need any soap i can buy
you some soap if you need to keep up on
your hygiene
uh no actually i mean you know i had the
soap
and the only thing i was missing was you
know uh
the the towels thank you
do you know where to buy towels
have you bought towels made all these
all my friends look like complete
[ __ ]
thank you thank you so much for doing
that
your dad's throwing things away
we give them gifts that show our true
love for them
actually you know what we do give our
dad a coffee we give him coffee the
coffee is he already like around the
world he gets like a new coffee is a
good gift but like
my dad already buys coffee for himself
he doesn't buy towels
i'll give him like a
portable heater
again because i've been getting coffee
for years yeah i know that's like a kind
of a cop-out gift
i got my dad uh as opposed to towels
i got my dad a
a thing to line his rod fishing rods
like you can a spool thing to line his
fishing rods because my dad is a fish
i'm saying it's a thoughtful game do you
want fishing rods well if you do go
fishing and you fall in now you have
some towels
yeah
uh you have to put the fish in something
yeah you might as well clean them up
with the towels
they're very
versatile is that why it's for you your
towels have holes in them because fish
keep swimming through them
uh but yeah we just wanted to clear that
up
uh i'm glad you called and i'm glad i
was available to um consult with you i
am very glad on that as well and i think
all my friends have a very hard lesson
to learn
that's what you want a long hard look at
myself i still think i still think it's
a shitty game i think
is the the one ton air compressor i got
my dad last year for christmas is just
so stupid in hindsight now i'll call you
later now that i know i could have
gotten off inside 600 air compressor
you're telling me i could have gotten
away with 30 towels yeah dude okay well
just imagine you're sitting in a group
in a groove and everybody's opening
presents
and like you're the guy that gets
deodorant because you're musty no but
everyone knows it'll be like
10 minutes i'd be like sweet i am gonna
need this like three times this year
and it's gonna take up half my garage
but you know you need an air compressor
but it's like you can use the air
compressor to dry off are you guys ready
to like admit that you're wrong or i
already said i was wrong well i don't
regret it riley was your dad before this
just coming out wet all the time but no
oh my god you want to know something
crazy we are learning doesn't use towels
right now he didn't know he could borrow
our towels
you can use a towel we didn't know this
was he just shaking off like a dog oh he
didn't have to no because philip dude we
have like 20 towels what was he using
paper towels i don't want to use them
but your dad would love him
that's riley's dad
and we're like and then philip said it
one day and i'm like no way every day i
looked at blonde i go do you not use a
towel but here's the thing this guy's
weight is insane i'm like grab a [ __ ]
towel dude it's just an air dryer i
waited till christmas to get them towels
you guys are [ __ ]
dude i mean
i'll get below some towels
i am a giver of towels
you look like a towel yeah i am a towel
you should get him a [ __ ] pitcher for
his uh his father's day you should get
him a picture of mr towel saying like
happy father's day
for next chris i'm taking away his
towels
right here and then i'm giving back
you're going to india that's how you
learn to appreciate the towels
you gave them a ball what kind of ball
was that
[Laughter]
in a trash can paul
you could throw this like oh you got me
a ball
you probably just imagine like a red
star on it and it's got like a yellow
stripe and a blue stripe just like
playing it like did you guys imagine you
make it like the thing from uh castaway
making like a wilson so he had a friend
oh yeah we got you a ball so you could
have a friend in the house what does
your dad do for a living he sounds so
happy
uh
i he's a towel salesman oh [ __ ]
i forgot how i'm asking questions
guys he's a psycho analyst let's be
serious oh so that so he
it was the smart it was the best thing
the smartest thing to do is to uh be
supportive and and cheerful of your
ideas as a gift
your dad's a psychoanalysis yeah he
knows all of you guys his problems now
is he a viewer probably not smart did
you know that
did he know he should have read to you
more as a kid
like every time he calls he feels he
understands how important it is right to
always answer that call with a positive
attitude that he needs because riley
looks like he didn't receive another
touch as a kid
it looks like he's kept in a basement
with no windows
he's like allergic to the sun now dad's
like damn
i should give him these towels back so
we have some shade you know
yeah what if he just hates the towels
and he's just saying that for the
podcast yeah father i talked to him
later he's like don't [ __ ] do that
[ __ ] again
these [ __ ] towels are gonna hang
myself with something that's what
they're good for he sounds so happy man
he's like a happy guy
he was really appreciative yeah you know
he's like i love the [ __ ] trash can
[Laughter]
you kids bought me a trash can
is he knows how to appreciate the little
things how's your mom who knows he can
only appreciate the little things
because you only give them
a ball or a stick yeah
you're 23 or 24.
23. so you're like what at the age of 20
you gave him a ball
that was the first game did you kids
chip in
he was like he played with that ball
every [ __ ] day he was like he was
like oh riley and then he shook your
little smiley face cap
he said thank you for the ball he said
he always plays with the ball every time
riley steps in the room he's like yeah i
still love it buddy
every day every day i imagine he just
picks it up and he's like huh look at
that
isn't that nice and then he he throws it
in the trash can he bottom of the year
the towels are there too
oh it's a gift to contain my other gifts
thanks for the trash can now i can now i
know that would
it all comes together
and he puts all of your gifts for the
next like 10 years in the trash can and
at the end of the 10 years he's like
guys these are the gifts you have gotten
and then he takes him and throws them at
you
and this is my will none of you are on
it it's like a time capsule people in
the future just horrible i hope your dad
starts like getting back at you with
gifts he starts giving you shitty gifts
like one year he gives you tic tacs
here you go [ __ ]
savor them i'm kind of curious on what
what are the embarrassing stories they
will say about you like if you brought a
girl home or something
what do you oh do you know that right oh
yeah dude my mom would be really
embarrassing dude
hey one time i brought a girl home and
my mom was on the phone with my aunt and
she goes oh my god justin brought a
woman home he's not gay
while she was standing right there your
mom's smoking a cigarette she's pregnant
doesn't smoke hans she's not asian okay
she's got a hand on the head
oh look justin came back with the woman
and then and then she started oh my mom
talking
she has a friend over she's like oh i
thought he was gay girl
hans what does your mom sound like oh
how's that girl i thought he was gay i
just had another threesome today that
was awesome oh very very special and
he's a very special boy he's very funny
one time he is the golden everybody is
nice
wait listen to eddie's asian accent do
that one more time eddie would do it one
more time
that sounded just like your mom or
something my mom try it one more time
please do it do a han's mom please i
didn't do it i didn't do a woman i did a
man oh well
all these dogs you guys want to end it
i'm hungry yeah we've been doing it for
like
how long have we been doing this for
like three hours
let's just talk one more thing about the
holocaust
so you want to read i want to read this
one last comment real quick before we go
on about the holocaust again some guy
said just remember one thing whatever
you say here will be with you your whole
career actually just the racist stuff no
one cares about whatever else you say
dude i don't give a [ __ ] you're loud
you're wow dude thanks for making it so
depressing yeah who wrote that comment
that wasn't depressing
that cancer culture [ __ ] like are we yes
we are gang dude unless you're like
raping women look here's what i got on
cancer culture bro if you can't control
your feelings or emotions stop trying to
control people's behaviors bro
facts bro who are you kyle renton house
dude
let's go shoot some protesters
thank you
not guilty
he's not guilty
guilty
not guilty not guilty
there's
why is there so many baby cats what is
this kyle kitten house oh my god smitten
for a mitten kyle
i don't have any kyle written house
material but hey i didn't write any
things for kyle rit
this this this protest is kind of lit in
the house
yo dude kyle rittenhouse is pretty lit
for what he's got a pretty nice set of
kyle titan houses on here
he's like this is gonna blow up
probably most likely
i think the courts know that too that's
one little quick sound for me i think i
think that words were giving i think
they were getting a lesson i think they
were giving giving the whites one back
you know for all the mistakes they've
been doing to white people lately
i think they're like we gotta give we
gotta give the whites one more and then
it's only fair it's only fair
it's like the mercy rule yeah like they
[ __ ] up the last few years with white
people in the justice system so i think
we get one back you know what i i i
think that happened at the capitol what
look what they did to white people at
the capitol they shot one and that was
not right
one was gonna say that uh
i i disagree but uh that's just me wow
that sounds pretty racist dude is it
because they're white
i i'm just saying that whatever your
statements were i just disagree with all
of it
all of it all of it hey do you think
kyle renhouse was at the capitol too
protect your neck oh yeah
i see eddie's angle here i think he was
trying to lie low but as soon as we get
off stage he's going to drop three hard
hours he always does
let's just well he's positive because i
can say i can say that and and uh that's
brown privilege
you can't say that i can say what
there's certain things you can't say
that i can oh like what everything i
like
anything and everything i can say that's
three to two
okay we're done
okay thank you not guilty guilty
guilty